good morning members good morning
members of the public you're all very
well from here this morning for today's
plan and meeting just before we start
I'd just like to introduce the my
colleagues here on the top table for the
members of the public to be aware who
they are they start with the Solicitor
General plenum I switched on now my name
is Ian Debray I'm a solicitor I'm here
today to be legal adviser to the
committee myself hopefully I can be
heard now my name is Ian to pray I'm a
solicitor I'm the legal adviser to the
committee good morning I'm not Russell
I'm the area planning manager good
morning I'm Robert Carmichael governance
Support Officer Jack Wilkinson and
principal planning officer I'm Claire
Phil pork government support officer
need to be a chairman of the plan
committee members on my right are
members of the planning committee and I
will introduce them as they speak they
do have their name plates in front of
them and the board member Kessler
horridness up I'm at my left your right
okay
we'll continue our first asked the
officer to read a of the health and
safety regulations Thank You chair
mayor first remind you some domestic
arrangements toilets are situated
outside the meeting room opposite the
livers
cold water is also available in the
breakout area opposite delivers if the
fire alarm should sound please leave the
meeting room via the follow following
the fire exit signs and meet on the I
tips which town training pitch and
remain there until you are told it is
safe to return and I could I please ask
that you switch off all mobile phones or
turn them to silent thank you Jeff
thank you I'll just read those the
illegal the cancel members of the public
and press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and press are not lawfully excluded any
member of the public who attends a
meetin and objects to being filmed
should have a file used the committee
Clark as far as I'm aware no one has
indicated that they will be filming or
that they do not want to be filmed is
that still the case that's thank you in
accordance with the council's plan and
charter members of the public are not
permitted to communicate where the
thurber T or in Brighton with members of
the committee during the course of this
meeting including any adjournments if a
member of the committee is approached by
a member of the public they must
immediately draw to my attention and
also to the attention of the legal
affairs are present if a member of the
public attempts to communicate with a
member of the committee then they may be
asked to leave the meetin I would like
to remind everyone present that this
meetin will be broadcast live to the
Internet and will be capable of repeated
viewing the whole of the meetin will be
filmed except where there are
confidential or accept items which I
don't think there are any
if you make a representation to the
meetin you will be deemed by the council
to have consented to being filmed and to
the possible use of those images and
sound recordings for webcast and and/or
train and purposes
finally can members and officers please
ensure that you press the microphone for
speaking and turn off when you're
finished and it is important members
that you get close to the mic so that
they can the public can hear you thank
you item 1 substitutes and apologies I
think we just have one pencil Aharon
chairman good morning I am substituted a
for David Busby thank you so chair we
have an apology from councillor Owen
this morning Thank You chairman if I
might just to because there's a lot of
people here who might not be aware of
our usual procedures as we've just noted
councillor Herron is here today as a
full member of the committee
substituting for the absent councillor
Busby he would have been invited in any
event to speak but not vote as the ward
member my understanding from my
conversation this morning with
councillor Hernandez he's chosen on the
Box had items who sit apart and speak
but not votes then he'll rejoin his
colleagues for the rest of the committee
and that is quite acceptable thank you
all right item two declarations of
interest do thank you I've just had a
thought and not sure whether it's
relevant for this committee but I am an
employee of schools choice and in that
capacity I work with both Boxford and
what field schools
to advise their teacher that's a
non-pecuniary interest it can just be
noted no problem
you can continue to sit in the meat and
then cake part a cancer Jamison yeah
look the declared interest in the what
field application design the world
member for what field I'm sure I mean so
when on that item counselor Jamison will
probably your usual practice is to
invite the ward member to begin the
debate isn't it German so that's that's
not so we thank you for mentioning we
don't need to formally notice at this
stage okay
Oh cancelados but you have to think of
mr. chairman odd
it's two items 6d Sudbury Sudbury
southeast it's the crown building Newton
Road I have declared a non-pecuniary
interest in previous meetings when this
has come to to count to committee and
it's an on procuring basically that I
have the residence in Bellevue Road I
have advised on policies but nothing
else and I've kept well away from
anything else
I'm sorry counselor huh chairman thank
you although it has been mentioned I
think I should officially declare an
interest on item one land east of Sand
Hill as I cannot really claim to be
impartial
thank you very much scan Sahara right I
think we can nail these are actually
true chicken for the minutes we haven't
received them yet but they are on their
way but I asked the officer to comment
Thank You chair just to confirm with
regards to the minutes that we were
waiting legal sign off on those from the
last committee so my colleagues are
still working on a draft and they will
be presented to the committee at the
next sorry at the next committee thank
you thank you yes they normally have to
be signed off by legal it's just taking
a bit longer this time right we moved to
item four sorry tensley before you move
on from the minutes I believe and I was
present the last meeting we did actually
say that a the slough road ransom
application would just come back to this
committee meeting for the approval of
the reasons for refusal as we haven't
got any minutes and the minutes would
have said that that would be coming back
to this meeting for
approval of the reasons for refusal why
have we not got it before us today I'm
not sure that we actually said was
coming to this meet and I think the
words I might have used was at the very
next convenient meet and that we could
get a two but I'll check for you I
presume that I presume that the officers
nodding their heads will have been
listening to the the transcript of this
of that meeting because I they weren't
actually present at that particular
meeting but we gave that the reasons it
was just a question of the detail being
filled in by the officers okay thank you
for asking that question you're quite
right and one of the area managers Joe
Hobbs was here for that meeting and
she's been on leave she's back now so
we'll get it to the next one that we can
and she was at the meeting so she'll
know what the reason should be thank you
so it's the next one that she can get it
too yep Mike which might be the next
beaten but it may not be one of the
reasons for these fortnightly meetings
was that there was a backlog of
applications that we had to get through
now it appears the backlog is in the
paperwork to catch up with the meetings
so perhaps we should revert to monthly
meetings and then we can't actually
conclude the business fully on those
meetings your point is taken that I
think at the moment the meetings are as
lining day but we we did say that we try
and get it back as quickly as possible
and so that's what we will try and do
and members of the
but rather than you stained you're
welcome to come through the door and sit
on that back row over there
that's the officer you can just go and
pointed out to them yep you're right
just keep going on there
try not to press the mics though please
thank you right we'll move to item four
now and that is to receive notifications
of any petitions Thank You chair we have
one petition to report to committee this
morning it is in respect of the first
item on the agenda this first
application that will be discussed by
committee it is signed by 144
signatories of the following statement
we the undersigned petition the planning
committee of David District Council to
reject the Catesby estates application
referenced AC 1901 873 to build 80 new
homes on land to the east of Sand Hill
boxford in a locally important rolling
Valley Farm land area with poor access
to boxford Village thank you thank you
so we have noted that and that's been
done any other petitions no G right then
we'll move on to item 5 which is site
inspections officers do you have any
site inspections no members know we're
all got next Wednesday off we'll move on
to item 6 and that is plan an
application to be termed by the
committee will take 6a which is on page
file you've can I just ask do members of
the public hips some copies of the what
we're dealing with if you handed over
any copies around you've handed over all
that we've got
I am page five land at Easter sands Hill
boxed at Suffolk the case officer is
Jack wilkinson over to you jack
there's obviously a short delay with
technology here oh here we are Thank You
chair good morning members members of
the public I'm Jack Wilkinson principal
planning officer first item is item 6a
it's an outline planning application for
the erection of up to 80 dwellings
including vehicular access land to the
east of Sand Hill Inn Boxford first
aspect we'll be looking at as a
principle of development including
access to this core village
which one this one
so as mentioned already has an outline
application for up to 80 dwellings this
was expressly requested for a member
site visit last week by councillor Brynn
Horan interests of assessing the site
firsthand on the ground
members did undertake that site visit
last week on the 18th in terms of
location were located to the east of
Boxford north of the Aon B as shown the
site is located on the east to the north
of Hadley Road which runs along south
and we have Sand Hill along the west in
terms of connectivity to the larger
towns in terms of Hadley to the east and
Sudbury to the west support it's a 5.7
one hectare site
apologies is a 5.7 one hectare site
bound to the north by domestic property
and also by an exception site to the
Northwest Sand Hill to the left
Hadley rode along with domestic
residents along the South the eastern
boundary is relatively open I'm into the
agricultural nature these are all the
constraints which I will break down in a
moment and we will talk through that and
effectively the site as outlined in pink
members may wish to note the public
right-of-way which runs through the
center of the site off left and indeed
off right that is part of the definitive
map we also have the conservation area
boundary and also deeper into the heart
of the village the flood zone
identification by the muddled ei flood
maps there's also tpo tree belt along
the north which is outside the
application site so in breaking down
those constraints that are of material
consideration as I've said the public
right-of-way which runs through the
center again definitive map which links
off towards this part of box which I'll
come on to later this line here is the
outline of the conservation area as you
can see there is some distance between
the application site proper and the
conservation area and indeed the heart
of Boxford village in terms of flood
zones 2 and 3 they are effectively laid
out as shown the site is not within any
identified flood zone other than flood
zone 1 whereas most parts of the country
are indeed part of flood zone 1 this is
not within a concerning area in terms of
the local flood authority comments there
is no objection raised from the local
flood authority infiltration tests have
been undertaken and the site is readily
capable
of accommodating the development
proposed and indeed any sealed surfaces
I've chosen to highlight the public
rights-of-way
in a more bold color mainly so you can
see that but also so that you can
understand where it takes you to and
from bearing in mind the connectivity
from the eastern part of Boxford the
final slide in terms of constraints
outlines the relationship to the
built-up area boxford as a core village
we have the defined outline of the
built-up area you can see that the site
is suitably related in terms of the
spatial layout and its relationship to
this part of Boxford and it is
worthwhile noting we are in the
countryside education however we do a
join and in that regard cs2 is engaged
as it's CS 11 in terms of its
relationship to the core village looking
at an aerial this is an agricultural
piece of land much of babe remand
Suffolk is classified as grade 2 & 3
agricultural land this is a grade 3 site
1 being the best quality agricultural
land 5 being the worst as I've said the
majority of baver is class 2 and 3 and
there's no reason to discredit the
application on that basis given the
location of the district this is the
indicative master plan provided by the
applicant as you can see whilst this is
not fixed it does show the quantum of
development the lowest lying point
towards the northwestern corner one
element that is fixed that I will go on
to discuss in a moment is the access
it's also worth noting as well members
again you may recall we stood just where
I've indicated with the marker
looking up out of the valley the land
rises from west to east across the
agricultural land this is a view from
that gate which we viewed last week you
may wish to follow the arrow along the
bottom left-hand corner which shows
where the photo was taken from
projecting to this is a view from Hadley
Road down into the valley it's a view
east you can just about to see the crest
of the hill along the southern boundary
and the lowest line point to the left of
the gate where we stood this is along
the northwestern corner this is from the
highest point taken on site in terms of
the boundary which we can obviously see
from the red outline looking down into
what is currently the exception
exception sight into what would be the
village you can't
in essence see the main bulk or heart of
the village because the land does
continue to drop as we know this is an
inner sight view you can just about see
the well-trodden public right-of-way
that is marked through again that's on
the definitive map issued by Suffolk
County Council you can see the biggest
and best trees that are located off site
these are protected by TPO and the scale
of the exception housing so back to the
indicative plan and I'd like to look at
a few aspects of this which are in
essence bound by section 106 so as part
of the 80
paison 35% is for affordable housing we
also have highways improvements along
with a minimum public open space
provision I think that's important to
secure that in the interests of so for
instance you are - to approve a reserved
matters application comes in those
aspects are are dealt with that's in
your papers as reported so zooming in on
the access if I may we have Sand Hill
which leads on to be preferable to
Hadley Road it was actually Hadley Road
from the right-hand point on the the
earth map it shows a diptych tribe its
Hadley Road it's a 40 mile amount of
stretch I'd like to jump into the detail
of the actual configuration of that
access as you will note hopefully you
can just about see it the access is at
this point and I have chosen to jump
through and again this is the defined
redline outline including the access
splay and width along with the frontage
and again the access point here it's
important to consider the visibility
splay which is secured at 68 meters that
is above and beyond local highways
Authority recommendations it's also
worthwhile noting as well members again
you may recall when we looked on site
the 40 mile an hour signs are located at
this point here the speed signs as part
of the proposal there would be an
extension of the 30 mile an hour zone
right up to what would be the 40 mile an
hour stretch so you've got a 40 mile an
hour stretch along paddy Road into the
dip and out this section here will be
made 30
looking right out of sight again a two
point for me to set back in the same way
that we did for looking left it secured
a hundred meters again this is above and
beyond
highways requirements if you look at the
Navy our Allah set 120 metres dependent
on foliage
and again this is a 30 mile an hour
stretch down into the hill so in terms
of pedestrian foot way connectivity is
going to be a crucial part of no doubt
what you will discuss and debate
connectivity into the heart of Boxford
is a fundamental feature as such the
developer is look to include a new foot
way that leads into the center of the
village and as as highlighted in yellow
residents could in essence walk from
site via the public footpath which would
be of good quality and that is secured
through agreement I've had to break up
the actual view of the connectivity into
the village given the distance into some
concise slides hopefully you can relate
in terms of the planned and as
highlighted the proposed foot way you'll
note the proposed foot way as shown on
the right here this is the access inter
station field we parked just off shot
and we were able to walk from this point
down into the village and I don't see
that being an issue in terms of access
for residents
this is the footpath that we walked
leading down into the center and again
this is the area that we gathered upon
so if Sand Hill Ellis Street in Cox Hill
I referred earlier to the public
right-of-way which comes in and links
off to Cox Hill and Ellis Street on into
the center so residents would have a
choice ultimately if they choose to get
into their car and drive elsewhere they
do so but the same time they do have the
option and the option is that you can
use the public right-of-way or indeed
the pedestrian access that would be
provided and I will just highlight those
areas so that they are clear in terms of
what is to be proposed and provided in
yellow as a means of public footpath the
green outline is an improvement to the
bus stop and we have consult with our
heritage colleagues and heritage
colleagues have no concern with these
features within what is now the
conservation area subject to materials
for instance further on into the heart
of the village the developer has
recognized that there are in some
instances some pinch points I could you
realistically Traverse down the footpath
pavement unhindered and with ease and I
think the identification of this point
for instance is in an aspect that it's
been carefully thought through and I
have just provided its a slight
exaggeration in terms of the the line
but it does show what is proposed and
that is to widen this section and the
proposed drawing which is accurate by
topographical survey is as shown so I
think it shows quite careful
consideration as to how pedestrians
could indeed walk from the site into the
center of the village so again back to
the map I will highlight these in a sec
but you can see that these yellow points
here demonstrate
where access could be made from and also
here in order to gain access and I have
highlighted that we have pedestrian
access along the South which is readily
available linking through there is a
section here where residents will have
to cross the road and I make that
crystal clear but you could walk into
site I think it's also worthwhile
mentioning the fact of the appeal case
at dating Avenue where by the inspector
resolved to conclude that the site in
that case was not acceptable in terms of
its access now the inspector was crystal
clear in his description of that access
for the pedestrian so he found that
there would be obstructions in terms of
wheelie bins in terms of telegraph poles
down Swan Street which is the other side
there would be a multitude of parked
cars and there would be an awful lot of
pinch points ie narrow points whereby
you couldn't necessarily walk down safe
instance you had a buggy now your
officers conclude in their assessment
along with the local highways authority
that there are large differences in that
case to this whereby there is good
quality footpath existing and proposed
so the link up between the site and the
heart of the village is acceptable as
opposed to what the inspector found in
the taking Avenue case and I think
members should be mindful of that as
they draw their own conclusions so just
to draw final summary it's a 5.7 one
hectare site with up to 80 units of
which 35% are for affordable housing the
spatial parameters for the affordable
ZAR fixed and set so the developer would
be required to provide homes that are
over suitable mix and tenure that would
be bound in the section 106 your
officers conclude that this is a core
village
and it is a sustainable location within
which there are adequate services and
facilities and amenities available that
is itemized in your report the access
for the vehicle is acceptable as per the
highways recommendation with no concern
from the flood and water engineer public
open space would also be included with a
management company to a minimum of 1.87
hectare that's a good space and your
recommendation of such is for approval
subject to the conditions kind of
contained within the report and 106
thank you
thank you can we have the lights back up
please but with members of the public
present we wish to speak
we have Phil Wallace parish council if
you serve like to come forward to the
front row at the end you have three
minutes in which to address the
committee and sit or stand whatever
suits you and at the end of that perhaps
should remain seated or standard and
I'll say there's any questions for you
thank you good morning everyone
my name is Phil Wallace I've lived in
Boxster for 20 years and I'm here to
represent the views of the parish
council Elizabeth Thomas the senior babe
a policy strategy planner is quoted her
her report back from 2019 saying the
proposal was significantly large and
disproportion of the existing pattern
former settlement the report clearly
shows that she understands the
difficulties the village faces with the
scale of this development this report is
included in the case officers report but
interesting a last paragraph was left
out and this stated the site is
unsuitable and undermined the merging
plan led approach to growth which
paragraph 49 a at the MPF f50 29 does
not support the size of the development
its location are not in keeping with the
desires and wishes of residents in a
poll carried out at the beginning of
2019 the parish counts from residents
and not opposed to development within
the parish the field should be in line
with the needs of the neighborhood plan
which is being implemented at the moment
calling
the smaller developments in the parish
and the proposal is at odds with their
local plan policy CS to the access road
from the development will exit under
sand hill where pedestrian access is
poor requiring pedestrians to cross the
road to enter the village creating
hazards for pedestrians further down
this one enters the village for Ella
Street there is also no footpath for
some distance and the road is narrow
with park cars resulting in pedestrians
having to walk along the road to access
the village CS 15 states that
connections between any proposal should
be continuous the proposals to put an
extra pathos was a result in the
reduction in the width of the rows
resulting in the increased problems with
traffic access and parking the increase
in traffic resulting from the
development would accelerate the
problems already encountered in the
village not only from the access to the
village from the development also in
other areas where traffic must readily
mount pavements to pass each other
Swan state input Street in particular
will suffer as relevance regularly use
this road to gain access to Barisan
Edmonds Newmarket and Cambridge the
issues relating to the congestion and
pedestrian safety were clearly upheld
during a decision regarding phase 2 of
Goodland development pedestrian safety
issues will be increased for the extra
traffic arising from the development in
particular line the safety of children
who either travel by foot tube oxford
school and those pupils gathering at
various points in the village to catch
buses two schools in Sudbury Hadley in
Ipswich where pupils have to wrigley
stand on the roadside waiting for buses
it is felt that highways have not taken
them account box add unique road system
have not considered the recent findings
regarding Swan Street during the
goodness development decision and the
already unsafe junction at Cox Hill and
Sand Hill the recent reduction in the
frequency of beestings bus service
between soccer in Ipswich will also
encourage residents to use their cars
for travel outside the village the
increase in school-aged children needing
placement will also have an impact on
the village at present although there
are some places at box 4 primary school
there were needs provision for pupils to
be place outside the village which will
increase traffic currently it's been
identified at the school cannot expand
in this present site and already is
taking pupils from stoper nail and
acetone and use in green where there
already new developments having been
built were in the process being built
which will invariably increase the
amount of pupils applying for places of
Boxford school in conclusion boxwood
parish council urges the committee not
to support this application taken into
consideration the letter from box for
parish council the views expressed by
our residents in writing and verbally to
the committee and in particular the
report from Elizabeth Thomas to the case
officer Jack Wilkinson
or this year thank you thank you sir
members is there any questions you wish
to put to the speaker councillor Barrett
thank you and you told us you concerns
about footpaths and safety of
pedestrians what do you think of the
what we've heard from the planning
officer about the improvements to their
the footpaths and do you think that
would address it I feel that residents
are still going to have to cross that
road on Sand Hill but further down when
you come into well as Street the
proposal to put in a new footpath on the
left-hand side going down there's an
embankment there which I'm led to
believe is actually privately owned if a
foot party's been going to put in there
it's going to then reduce the size of
the road there because cars paths long
where that foot part is going to be so
it's going to create more pinch points
as well thank you any other questions
Kent Kent sir Parker
I'm super sorry about that could you
tell us miss Wallace do you know with
the addition of potentially 80 new homes
what percentage increase that will
result in in in terms of numbers of
houses within the village do you know
that information I believe that the
amount of properties we have our
residential properties in the village
amounts to around between 550 and 600 a
moment thank you Jemison you say this
the places in the local primary school
you know how many places in the long
term you know number of places that will
be available in the school I'm not quite
sure but I think there are around
between 15 and 20 places at present do
you know anything about the longer
County do have longer you know what's
coming up in terms of supposed to going
to describe I think answer the Jemison
that's really a question for the officer
I think they can give you the answer
that I'm not sure unless you knew but I
don't think it's a question for the
applicant for the Parish Council
counselor Barrett just one fun thought
question for you so currently we hypsi
understand from the report that there
are 18 pupils attending Boxford from
outside sorry
there are currently 18 pupils attending
boxford from outside the village do you
do you encounter problems with traffic
from those parents who have to attend
from outside of Oxford definitely yes I
mean we can counter problems with
residents in the village at the school
let alone people come from outside of
the village it's a major problem for us
at school times the Pitons entry next
year some school Thank You councillor
Norman thank you yes good morning and I
just well obviously you mentioned that
you're currently going through the
neighbourhood plan process I'm just
wondering if you carried out any type of
them housing needs survey or anything
like that to identify any sort of proven
local need for the housing requirements
and box
I'm not actually involved with the
neighborhood planning committee but I
did I was involved briefly with the poll
or a survey that was sent out towards
the end of our street beginning this
year and the residents were polled who
responded the majority felt that housing
these should be smaller houses one to
two three-bedroom houses with sheltered
accommodation and affordable housing not
large developments for small
developments between some are four to
five houses and infill developments as
opposed to big developments on the
boundary of the village thank you I'll
see if I can get our offices in due
course to clarify that point for you
remembers any other questions No thank
you very much okay comment on what
you've just heard and the question thank
you chair and as a point of clarity a
local housing needs assessment has been
undertaken by the developer and that
showed that there is a deficit in that
regard
the second point around schools and
capacity has been looked at in depth by
the development contributions manager
for Suffolk County Council and he's
identified that the school is in a
position whereby he would not be able to
expand by nature of the constraints that
affect the site mainly flood zone and
also the capacity in terms of space with
that in mind he has recommended that the
developer provide a contribution for
schools transport over a short period to
in essence bus pupils to nearby stipend
islands now that would be bound by a one
hundred and thirty four thousand four
hundred pounds contribution which would
be secured through the section 106 and
that would be the position on many a
development within Boxford or on the
edge of I think it's crystal clear that
the County Council have a duty and
obligation to deliver adequate provision
for schools whether it's new homes or
existing and that's what the developer
has agreed to comply with
thank you thank you right we have an
objector Chris Phil village you sir have
also three minutes you can sit or stand
and perhaps attend to that you'll remain
seated thank you we're servicing
questions good morning members my name
is Chris filbert I'm a resident of
Oxford and have been asked to speak on
behalf of the village a significant
issue with the scheme relates to
highways the lack of empirical testing
and local travel pans not being taken
into care into account firstly the case
officers report is misleading it
suggests a planning aspectus decision in
relation to an appeal for 24 house
houses at Goodland was to dismiss due to
existing highway safety and congestion
concerns on Swan Street and has been
considered it infers that this is not
comparable with the situation in Ellis
tree unfortunately this misses the point
if the Sandhill proposal was given
consent today the extra traffic
generated would accessor bait the
inspected Highway to concerns for Swan
Street
the desired path for journeys to Lavin
and berry and Beyond is up Swan Street
it's simply the most convenient roof of
villagers new houses in boxwood would
increase the traffic on Swan Street and
I would direct members to paragraph 21
of the inspectors report on that case
which which finds that even a minor
increase in traffic on that road is
unacceptable the applicants transport
assessment merely provides a screen grab
of google google map travel times
suggesting a journey from boxer to berry
versa 3 is 1 minute quicker than the
Swan Street route this is simply not the
case and villagers preference is to
avoid peak time queues at the a 107 1 a
1 3 4 Junction and elsewhere through
Sudbury especially now that the lowest
speed limits have been put into place
secondly neither the case officer
highways nor applicant consider the
impact of the extra traffic through the
narrow pitch point this Stonestreet
Bahamut the the decide routine to
cultures 2 for commuters the proposal
would increase traffic here and there
are regular holdups I know of at least
one listed house there which has been
hit twice recently cause
extensive structural damage thirdly the
high-waist proposal to introduce a
pavement on Ellis tree fails to
understand local traffic movement and
issues which will be worsened by both
the changes and the extra traffic
generated by the scheme it will
significantly narrow the road on an 80
meter stretch which is blind at both
ends with no refuge this is compounded
by the blind junction of Sand Hill and
Cox Hill the latter which does not have
a pavement and the steps of number 22
Ellis tree are frequently hit by
vehicles
so in summary members the highway
offices response has not taken any local
knowledge of travel patterns into
account and simply takes the applicants
submission as red Shirley before such a
significant decision is taken for the
village we need a reliable approach to
understand current and future traffic
patterns the application and analysis
before members has not tested travel
plans properly nor has it listen to
local views most notably it ignores the
planning inspector president visa vie
the scheme beyond Swan Street the
applicant the application needs to do to
follow due process the precedent is
clear here please do not make a folly
decision purely on what google tells us
thank you
thank you for that members do you have
any questions
councillor Jemison why you mention this
one Street but the road is it Cox hill
or Cox Road that goes off the Kersey how
busy is that coming down to the Sand
Hill Junction the reason I mentioned
Swan Swan Street is because of the
travel journey of villages to barrister
Edmunds and because of the decision
taken on the good lands appeal people
will travel along that road and because
the inspector has suggested that any
minor changing the traffic movements on
that road is unacceptable I believe that
due to the a teahouse has been built on
Sand Hill people will use that Road and
will increase the traffic movements on
that road be above and beyond what the
planning spectra is suggested using and
i I do think they the the applicant has
made some attention I do think you've
answered the question thank you
otherwise they later go into much debate
I've got allowed others and my part of
that and any other questions no okay
thank you very much is there anything
you wish to comment I did note mislead
and the fact that the inspectors report
perhaps you ought to just emphasize that
again bearing in mind the comments made
by the objector of course thank you
chair I think it's for members to
consider route in terms of where
residents would potentially drive to or
from and there's no reason to say that
residents would not go off to Ipswich or
indeed to Sudbury yes absolutely it's a
fair point in terms of residents would
have that option of driving down Swan
Street to Cambridge or Barrie for
instance but I think you need to take
that in the round and that is that there
is also access to other key towns so
I'll leave that for now thank you
because there is Colchester as well
surely Colchester is nearer than berry
it's going to be in a similar sort of
catchment and distance ultimately
Colchester is accessed via different
rope and members will arrive at their
own conclusions on that thank you
[Music]
the applicants an agent ed Barrett and
David Neal
mr. near there's a transporter
consultant so between you you have three
minutes and then I'll see if there's any
questions for you at the end of it
Thank You chair my name is ed Barrett
and I'm the senior planning manager at
Catesby estates the applicants in
concluding that the proposals before you
represent sustainable development the
officers have factored into their
balancing exercise the significant
benefits which will be delivered these
include the provision about the 28 much
needed affordable homes average house
prices in Boxford are currently more
than ten times the average salary in the
district and your offices correctly
recognized at the proposed policy
compliance affordable housing weighs
heavily in favor of the proposals to
encourage walking to local facility
facilities the proposals will deliver an
extension to the existing footway on
Sand Hill providing a continuous off
carriageway link to the village center
in addition the existing foot way on the
northern side of Broad Street will be
what widened where there is an
identified pinch point these
improvements will also benefit existing
residents and schoolchildren who
currently walk within the carriageway in
response to the comments raised at our
public consultation event the
improvements incorporate in a large
waiting area adjacent to the bus stop at
the bottom of Sand Hill it's what our
schoolchildren to wait glare of the road
the surfacing of the existing footpath
running between the station field
development and Brookville Road will be
improved to ensure it provides a good
usable walking connection to the village
and fellatio purposes importantly the
Highway Authority have confirmed the
proposals meet their requirements and
will not have a severe impact on highway
safety or capacity the improvement
scheme has also been subject to an
independent road safety audit verifying
that the proposals constitute a safe and
suitable link for pedestrians I'm joined
by our transport consult mr. Neal he'll
be happy to answer any questions you may
have on the proposals responding to
local residents desire for smaller
dwellings 60% of the properties proposed
in our master plan are 2 and a
three-bedroom in size including a number
of bungalows and maze nets the increased
choice of new homes will allow growing
families and first-time buyers to remain
within the village as well as enabling
older residents to downsize in line with
national trends Boxford is experiencing
an increase in the proportion its
population aged over 65 and the working
age residents will make a positive
contribution to the sustained
ability of the village helping to
support local services and facilities
the size of the site will mean that
we'll have strong interests from local
and regional house builders and this
development will assist in bolstering
the district's housing the supply and
delivery record as it is immediately
deliverable reflecting our confidence of
this we are committing to an obligation
requiring the reserve matters be
submitted within 18 months of the grant
of an outline and planning permission in
summary no objections have been received
from any technical or environmental
console tees the sight is logical and
the proposals before you will set the
parameters for a high-quality
and sensitive scheme reflective of the
character of the village the benefits of
the proposal are considerable and ask
you to follow your officers
recommendation and vote in favor the
application thank you thank you very
much members any questions councillor
Osborn first Thank You mr. chairman just
two questions really first of all the
suite just two questions really and it
involves your representation to the
council to the parish council can I be
assured that you have been with them on
a lot of the objectives that you wish to
seek on this application and secondly
are you likely to continue the design
that is on that section of housing just
before you come through the gate where
we stood for the site visit would that
be on the same good outlook and and
design we've met with the parish council
and the neighborhood bank group and also
held a public consultation event in the
village met with residents and we did
make a number of amendments to the
proposals following those discussions
it's an outline planning application so
we're not setting the detailed design of
the properties that will be done when a
house builder is selected for the site
they will need to submit their details
as a reserved matters planning
application which again will be
consulted on and discussed with with
local residents and they will need to
meet the requirements
the local authority in terms of in terms
of design so they may not be identical
to the adjacent development you know
hopefully even even better but but that
will be open for your consideration at
that point and did you get an answer to
the second part of your question thank
you sorry miss chairman it was in
relation to the design which I
overlooked the position that it's only
an outline application I just wanted to
know that he would continue or the the
agent would hopefully get the same good
design as we've seen it really around
that site that would come back to us
intercourse anyway
cancel a Norman thank you and yeah I
just you and thank you very much for of
the yeah I think you've circulated this
to all members the document that you
sent through with the information
regarding to the scheme I just wanted to
query on here when you talk about the
key development features it mentions a
maximum of 80 new ohms obviously and I'm
just wondering are you are you expecting
that to decrease or come down at all
obviously vendors when you say maximum
and if it was to decrease would that do
anything to the proposed affordable
housing that you're proposing or change
the makeup of the other bedrooms or
anything like that yeah a bit like the
answer to the first question the number
of units will depend on the House bill
when they when they purchase a site from
from us the maximum is 80 they could go
less depending on their layout and how
they design the site the affordable
requirement is is a pro-rata percentage
35 so yes if they the were less the
reserve matter stage the affordable
would be proportionately lower but it
would still be in line with policy yes
if we reminded to approve it
the backstrom would be 80 but there
could be less but either way that would
come back to us cancel aberrant this
might have already been discussed I
might have missed it but I just wonder
does it's a the site is sort of rising
to the
south east south west I think will you
have a plan for a single story being
more on the brow of the hill or have you
got to that stage yet yeah there's a
range of detail in the design and access
statement that we submitted and that
starts to establish a number of
parameters for the site while not
setting the absolute detail it shows
where the built development would sit
with a landscape buffer around the edges
of the site and it'd be nestled down as
far as possible into the lower parts of
the site and yet higher properties would
be more sensitive locations they're not
you know a blanket spread they would be
dotted that particular features on
corners of streets etc in the right
location and again that would be the
detail that you would be able to
consider at the reserved latter stage
I'll get the planning officer to clarify
that point when we get to him in a
moment
thank you cancel the areas thank you
Thank You chairman um can I just ask in
within that the plans would some of
these be at homes for life because it's
very important now that people would
move there and want to remain depending
how their health I'm not sure of the
exact local policy on homes for life if
that is part of the core strategy or the
new local plan then yes the reserve
matters would need to be in accordance
accordance with that I think Building
Regulations are sort of overtaking that
local policy now and and it does
incorporate some of those requirements
untold councillor Ayers that we cannot
give you answer to that in the moment
come back - any other questions - the
applicants and the highway expert their
consultant sorry it's only Suffolk
County Council highways have experts and
the other comments no okay counselor
Hinton
just one quick questions - mr. chairman
you mentioned when you were answering
council Norman's question about a
reduction in reduction in number of
homes etc that you will be getting the
planning permission and then selling the
saikhan to somebody else to actually
develop is that correct that's correct
KT estates are a land promoter
we don't typically develop homes
ourselves so we would market the site
openly to national regional and local
house builders select a partner who we
would then transfer the land to and they
would proceed with reserve matters for
the site thank you any other questions
thank you very much would you like to
comment on what you've just heard if I
may yes chair and in answer to
councillor Barrett's question concerning
what would effectively be landscaping
and indeed building heights yes the
agent is quite right that would come
through a detailed design however it's
also important to note that the
landscaping would be a fundamental
feature of the next phase if members are
minded to approve there's nothing before
us that would stop us from creating a
scheme that would be sensitive in that
regard so that's what we will consider
at that point in terms of councillor
Ayers as a question mix and tenure is
fixed there would be a mix 75 percent of
affordable rent and 25 percent shared
ownership that would be a district-wide
need in terms of the actual
accountability of homes for life that
will come through with their advice at
the time what is fixed obviously is the
percentage figure and that is 35 percent
so it would be proportionate relative to
the amount that is proposed if 80 comes
through and it's
The Cramps game we're gonna have to look
at something that is more acceptable and
that may mean releasing you know a few
more dwellings to enable space to create
a better scheme so it's up to for a
reason we do regain that control in
terms of the design and the layout
proper answers the design element and
deliver abilities being covered off by
at the agent and houses for life were
part of that answer with regards to a
full house and chair thank you
and I think it's fair to point out that
it's not unusual for applicants whether
they're companies or individuals to get
a planning permission and then they sell
it on to somebody else to develop I
think that that happens all the time but
it's been pointed out too so we are
aware that right I think we've now come
to there's no connector counselor so
it's the ward member councillor Brent
Allen you sir have five minutes in which
to address the committee and perhaps
should remain and I'll save us any
questions for you Thank You chairman
thank you very much good morning and
thank you to those who attended the site
meeting last Wednesday on behalf of the
people of Boxford I am very opposed to
this application and I do ask that you
turn it down today
this site has been subject of planning
and speculation before there have been
three attempts to put it into with the
core four sites the slurs we would know
it and it has been rejected every time
including about 18 months ago it has
also been considered by the Boxford
neighborhood bland team and it's
considered unsuitable and undeliverable
mainly through poor connectivity to the
village I would ask Jack could you put
slide 5 or 11 up on the screen please if
that's possible
the application it states and talks
about Weaver's green I would say there's
no such place as Weaver's green I wanted
to slide up so that you can see what
we're actually considering building on
it's a very very beautiful area with
rolling fields which are part of Boxford
and it's close to the Aon B and I think
more attention should be given to this
site for its actual merit it's a very
very beautiful piece of rolling farmland
and it's not an ideal place to build
it's also close to there MB as already
mentioned we was Green as a name that
the applicant has attached to this it's
actually station field because it's
where the old police station was in
boxford and why the development that's
the local needs at the bottom that's so
lovely was called station field we was
Green is an oddity really they give it a
pretty name before they cover the whole
lot with concrete and I would ask
members just to help us to preserve this
site the school has been mentioned it
has some capacity in the later years
because lots of people start off in
boxed at school and then they take the
map maybe for a private school or they
just move away so we do have spaces in
the later years but the in the lower is
Lea one year one it's actually four and
we've had appeals which have been turned
down and local people have been refused
which is very sad I note with interest
the county ganzo n-- summary where they
say that it probably won't be possible
for children off this site should it be
built to go to box fits goal they would
be bused like to I'm stoked by Nayland
which as it's just under the three miles
under the new county council policy
would not be free transport people from
boxford would have to pay two hundred
and fifty pounds of term
for that child to go out of the area to
another school and I think that is a
serious consideration there's also the
issue of the server surgery which is
basically one room divided into four
very little capacity there we are linked
to the main surgery at Hadley but once
again that's six miles away so it's yet
more travel we need a bigger surgery
desperately for the houses we've got
that there is very little chance on that
because like the school it is landlocked
so once again its development without
infrastructure and this will be a
problem the affordable housing gets many
mentioned and let's talk about the local
need and yes we do have a local need in
boxford it's in the 20s which is why
we've built in the past nearly 50
affordable homes and we probably do need
22 more but I must stress the homes
provided with this application are not
local they will not probably go to
boxford people they are general needs
which means we will suck more people in
from across the district and other
district to the North Norfolk down to
Essex
so I do stress this point this homes
predicted will probably do nothing
whatsoever for boxford's local needs
we've all seen and read the Elizabeth
Thomas letter and my god didn't she get
it right and I think I'm surprised that
after that this application then came
forward for approval at this committee
sequentially I feel and in boxford we've
always tried to build on the poorer land
and in this case of Sand Hill the field
continues to run to the river box where
the land there is much poorer you only
have to look at the crops to see that
that is the case and that would be the
preferred site for Boxford I am the
woman Thank You councillor Heron did
well at the time say okay Thank You Josh
it there
Thank You members is there any questions
you wish to cancel Hinton Thank You
chairman can siharan whereabouts
relative to this site is the primary
school and the doctor surgery and the
shops
piece of stone Street
if I can just interject obviously we
have the application site here as you
walk around slightly shape I'll be able
to dim the lights quickly sorry
so in effect you have the access through
here and thus called it's just on the
upslope from the river at this point
here and the doctors is over the other
side of the road close by possible jack
to bring up the plan of the village okay
well the again yes
yeah the surgery John is is that the
back of the village at the bottom of
Swan Street behind the post office if
you know boxford at all down a little
lane and the school is in as you go down
the bypass stone street is cut in half
and the school is in the the cutoff
piece from the bypass so it's it's quite
a journey around I hope that's helpful
that's the hint another question yeah
according to the MPP F facilities have
to be or ideally should be within 800
metres for walking distance to do
facilities schools doctors shops how far
would you estimate it is from the main
entrance to this site or from the rear
entrance by a pencil hint I'm struggling
to hear you can you get near to your
right according to the MPP F ideally
walking distance is 800 meters how far
would you say that the doctors the
school and the shops are from the both
the main entrance to this site and to
the the back entrance if you like by the
public rights away or permissive rides
away whatever they are I would estimate
council Hinton they are probably coming
off Sand Hill I would think it's about
two to three hundred metres
stand to Sandhill probably about four
down to the village you you probably get
just a bag get to the doctor surgery
within eight I think the school is
probably another hundred meters around
and probably just over would be my best
guesstimation I walk at many times but
I'm a quick Walker thank Thank You
Chancellor Hinton was referred to I
think the council of Columbia the
paragraph number I'll have a quick looks
I think they're different references to
different types of settlement okay okay
I think that's a worthwhile point in
terms of the distances if you look at
the chart Institute for Transport they
provide a staggered test if you like
five hundred meters being desirable
thousand meters being acceptable and
fifteen hundred meters being considered
members will make their own minds off on
whether this is within those parameters
that certainly the MPP F does provide
connectivity and the paragraph is there
for that thank you
any other questions councillor Parker
Thank You chair council Aharon you've
you've openly stated that you you oppose
this application and and you've just
asked this decision takers to do
likewise obviously you know as decision
takers if members were minded to do as
you've suggested and if members reminded
to refuse this application we have to do
so on on planning grounds now you've
you've quite rightly explained to us
your reservations about this application
so I would imagine that you have given
mine to the specific recommendations or
the specific policies that would enable
this committee to do likewise so have
you on what on what specific planning
grounds do you oppose this
application I think the main thing
councillor Parker is the the traffic
issues the pinch point coming down
illustrate I don't think it I don't
think it fulfills what it should do at
that point by a long way the inspectors
report mentioned the dangers to
pedestrians in Swansea thinking
farallon's cancer how enduring
highlighted the dangers I think
councillor Parker wanted to know reasons
or policies and I think you've got that
that you've got one on highways I think
I think orchards are sequentially aware
you build building on the poorest land I
I don't think it fulfills that also
chairman thank here we go that's very
common Jameson thank you I know this is
a bus stop at the bottom of Sand Hill
what east of us service like in Boxford
is there an alternative to using cars
there is a bus service I'm councillor
Jameson that recently has been cut one
of the main problems is getting children
to school we mainly feed a school for
Thomas Gainsborough but because of the
County Council changes that is also
changed and there is going to be more
more reliance on the private car it the
problem with Boxford is it's so narrow
roads all through it that it's barely
beginning to affect the shops and things
it's getting impossible to stop to buy a
paper to buy your meat and things like
that we are just clogged with cars
totally now and it's becoming the
overriding issue Thank You councillor
pump Thank You council hirin that brings
me to my question
this extra transport for children school
transport to stop an errand
would that be going up Swan Street no
that would not from the new site no that
would have access onto the 1071 I would
imagine that some of the other now due
to the change policy it does come down
and grow up strong Street that is great
thank you thank you
any other questions can't slow Barrett
yes and there are a lot of concerns
obviously about the the road traffic but
obviously in boxford itself it is purely
local traffic really isn't it because
you've got a bypass sure you're very
fortunate and in in that you've got a
bypass so surely it's quite slow moving
traffic that is mostly visiting a
location within the village and not
passing through no that's not quite
right councillor Barrett books videos
under sort of the highway West for Barry
and and places like that Stowe market
builder stone it tends to come down
swamp Street we've monitored Swan Street
several times and people it's getting
more and more and more and people do use
it as a cut through I think it's one
thing you notice about Swan Street and
Ellis Street I would say I'm 25 percent
of the journeys are with two wheels on a
pavement one side or the other they are
narrow streets if this goes ahead we
will make illustrate even narrower and I
do not see from measuring and pacing at
how we would even get a lorry up and
down it and if you build a pavement
it'll just be used as the highway same
as swamp Street is we suffer from a lot
of through traffic especially in the
last few years which is increasing I'm
afraid it's the how interpretation to
delay you to go on a bit on with the
answer any other questions cancer Parker
thank you cheers so given the answer to
your last question counsel Horan is it
is it just this development that you
would be opposed to or surely the answer
to your question rules out any
development
in the village of altered no councillor
Parker that's not right we would have no
problem finding places to put 50 houses
in boxford that are criteria it has to
provide infrastructure our preferred
site would provide a footpath over the
river against land cancel Helen I'm
going to stop you there in coastal
Parker I think we have to deal with
what's in front of us not what you think
might be or in the future okay any other
questions No thank you very much sir
than councillor Heron you're going to
remain there okay yeah you won't take
part anymore you know thank you jack is
there anything you wish to comment under
what you've just heard okay Thank You
members it's over to you then who'd like
to start
councillor Parker Thank You chef yep
I've got a number of questions actually
but perhaps I'll just come out and sorry
start at the beginning right okay so at
the beginning then with the table papers
with respect to this a particular agenda
paragraphs twenty one to twenty one
point two to twenty four point three
should be deleted which is interesting
because when I was reading the report at
the weekend I did actually make specific
notes of paragraphs twenty one point two
two twenty one point six so this we
don't have an explanation as to why that
has been deleted that first the reason
why those paragraphs are now deleted is
because that bill was quashed in the
court the winger Worth case which
follows I 21.5 is still active and does
still provide context in terms of
developments which are edge of
settlement with a land supply which is
as per the case here so that is a
materially
consistent case which is worth noting
thank you next question well can I come
back on that point then sure because the
one of the points I was you know I was I
wrote down over the weekend when I was
reading this is that the you know the
recommendation for the for the
application here a significant part of
the recommendation is precisely
paragraphs two and one point two to
twenty one point six and and what those
relate to our appeal decisions elsewhere
and so what it occurred to me was that
we were being asked to do here was to
say well although the the implication of
these paragraphs is that well actually
it's going to be really difficult to
turn this application down because of
appeals elsewhere and that seems that
seems to have a little bit of an arm up
the back scenario for us as decision
takers here so I'm interested to learn
that actually 21.2 and 21.3 have been or
the the appeal for that has been quashed
don't really have a point to that other
than just the fact that it is just a
statement chair that it does sort of
take out a large proportion of the
reason as to why we might recommend
approval on this I think it's an
entirely accurate and fair comment
we do still have to take a consideration
to precedent from the courts and indeed
appeals and the winger Wirth case is
prevalent that was issued by a very
senior inspector mr. Phillip where and
that concluded the edge of settlement
and indeed whether you know a LPA does
have a sufficient housing Lance applies
not a ceiling height five years isn't
the ceiling height it's whether the site
is deliverable and indeed whether in
light of all material considerations
whether the site is sustainably located
for instance this is the formed basis of
your recommendation the principle of
development yes I think your officers do
recognize that there is a degree of
tension with cs2 heightened by the fact
that there is currently allowance
apply but the general drive and boost
from government is that we need to
provide homes and the MPP F is clear in
that we still need to provide drip feed
we can't turn the tap off completely at
the same time it can't be one full blast
and forgive me for that analogy but I
think that summarizes where we need to
be in terms of retaining and maintaining
a land supply yes there is conflict with
cs2 if you're minded to look at that but
at the same time your offices feel that
the connectivity as demonstrated is
sufficient along with the infrastructure
and the principal being located edge of
settlement on balance and it is a fine
balance because there are lots of for
and against arguments here is on balance
acceptable and that's why the basis of
the recommendation is is formed thank
you both for answer there can still
perfect any other points no Chancellor
Jefferson you say the instructors here
yet we have enough places in the skull
we've got to ship out the stofan island
there's not enough space in the doctors
and the roads are all narrow I mean is
this a case of building more properties
without the infrastructure to
accommodate and again as part of the
balance and exercise which you no doubt
make I do concur with those comments to
a degree I think what is important is
there is provision in terms of a
footpath that we would secure and the
same way we would secure a contribution
for transport in terms of getting kids
to school that is the only feasible
option given that the County Council
have a requirement and duty to provide
school places for children of Boxford
and surrounding areas
there's no capacity at that school
that's recognized where you're providing
one dwelling or thousands that school
cannot be expanded it is constrained
heavily now you have to look at
elsewhere can make be in essence
transported elsewhere you have Hadley
high school you have the Thomas
Gainsborough in Sudbury in terms of high
school provision and you also have slope
and Island as cited in the report so
this is
the best option available for the
short-term Thank You Thomas Gainsborough
is in great cornered
apologies yet that's all right
sup we can't take credit for Thomas
going for a great corner does and cancel
a plum I think you were next
Oh J we've had some a good idea of how
you're gonna get down sand hill where
the pedestrians a village but now can we
look at the other side of the site
I wasn't can get the map up and you've
got a a right-of-way going through the
field that more or less splits the site
in half there it is and and then you've
got access into the village there how is
that access into the village from you're
alright with the first one
no it's go back one or two typica back
go back
yeah footpath goes to the middle of the
site and then how does that access the
verge so on the definitive map it shows
as there being a link from the
agricultural land as present to what
would NSS be look at e junction for the
pedestrian here you can then traverse
along west to an access onto Cox Hill
and down so so eventually it ends up on
Cox Hill yeah and so to get to services
in the village they then have to go down
Cox Hill they would have that option yes
there's a public right-of-way which
links off residents would have that
option of traversing in essence down Fox
Hill to where the bus stop would be and
is similarly you'd also have the option
along the south as we've been through
okay so we're talking about all of the
pedestrians are going to be coming down
Cox Hill where which is unpaved in many
parts particularly at the junction with
the the main road into the village okay
that's fine but you pilot with all the
tanks okay thank you can you put the
road to thank canceller park on yep
thank you jack um I'll come back to
counselor Jameson's point with regards
to school places if I'm a counselor with
Jess or because box food is the
catchments called box of Primus called
as the catchments golf or also Newton
Edison a Singh ttan and Groton as well
as Boxford so by natural extension
therefore this proposed development
would have knock-on effects for the
children from all of those villages as
well
which would have an unfortunate knock-on
effect with Suffolk County Council's
transport policy how material is that
factor to to our decision-making process
I think in terms of the cumulative
effect again it's a worthwhile point the
development contributions manager has
offered their advice with regards to
what could realistically be achieved
because you have to remember that we
have to provide school places not just
for boxwood but the surrounding areas as
you've quite rightly pointed now what
that comes down to is is another school
going to be built and in this instance
no not at this point in time there is
every chance that could happen in the
future where and how that's delivered is
is unfortunately not within our
jurisdiction
we can only go off with the advice which
is a short-term fix over a period of not
over a period of seven years in a
monetary contribution to deliver
accessibility for children of the site
to access schools if that means that
they go over into different parishes or
different schools that's part of the
overall consideration yes it is material
in answer to your question and it does
have tension with that element of the
policy but we have to deliver schools
and that catchment does provide that
thank you
any other comments members
Chancellor thank you I'm just thinking
about the the traffic generated through
the village and much of what we heard is
about the potential problem caused on
this site for traffic heading north
through using Swan Street but we have to
have to really think about is this
really credible that this is an
alternative that people would actually
choose from the proposed site where
they're very near to the
boxford bypass where they could access
it very easily or would they choose to
go through Swan Street that we've heard
is is a very difficult Street where you
have to stop and pull over and allow
other passing cars so I don't believe
that rational people do that do would
choose that route they would prefer to
get onto the the road that's the nearest
to their their house onto the bypass
which is very lucky to have and and and
then go towards whichever direction
Colchester or or north to Barry and and
we've heard a lot about the traffic
heading north to Newmarket Barriss Evans
and so on but eventually those vehicles
would join a major Road and so they
would logically go on to the box of
bypass so I really I really do struggle
with that aspect of what we've heard
today and for that reason that is
something I wouldn't be able to consider
if I was then minded to to consider
refusal on the the school places I know
from my experience that these small
rural villages really are quite
vulnerable to school places not being
taken up and and I mean I have
experience of what monks Ely closing
which was affiliated to to Botsford in
fact so I I'm and especially in view of
the fact that they've got 17 pupils at
out of catchment school from Stoke and
Ireland currently it's what I understand
it implies to me that in time we will
move to a position where those places
should be offered to families in the
village and that will reduce the
congestion of those parents driving from
Stolp on Ireland and actually clogging
up the the streets nearby the school at
the other end of the village away from
from this size so there's quite a
there's quite a balance here but on the
traffic and highways issue I'm leaning
towards approval on the school places
I'm leaning towards approval I just like
to check with anyone who knows do we
know if the health center is actually
accepting new registrations but for
people to register there
what kind of help on that at all I
haven't got that information - and I'm
wondering if we can quickly check and
get back - if we may we all find that
answer for you and as quickly as
possible but we all continue is there
any other questions any other debate any
other comments cancelados board Thank
You mr. chairman yes I completely concur
with councillor parrot on this one I
find it very strange that the 1071 won't
be used or the a13 for which goes either
way Barry
Colchester it's which Hadley even so you
know I agree absolutely with that the
other aspect is the position of
affordable housing now over the years I
know the ward member has always put
forward
needing the area within Boxford for
local residents
and I find it strange to believe that
you've got 28 affordable housing and
don't forget there's a hundred and ten
requirement additional houses per year
within the district and I'm sure that
and we've talked about this in you know
in other committees and that is that the
amount of affordable housing before the
district should be should be tended for
the district they're there for excuse me
there for areas of people coming in from
Essex and and surrounding districts
outside Suffolk or the dick or favorite
district in particular would be looked
at and I'm sure by condition that could
be put in on those affordable housing
and so therefore I've always been for
affordable housing and therefore I feel
that you have 28 affordable houses again
which according to wold member he
requires 22 of those so you know once
again me I can't find myself supporting
a refusal on this application thank you
do you do hear the comments about
affordable housing you do vote and
they'll come back to you in a moment yes
thank you chair I've just confirmed with
with these cg housing officer that there
would be a cascade a location within the
106 for that so the first priority would
be for people in the Botsford cluster I
box with and the surrounding villages
grow from there but still etc and there
would be available to people with a
paper connection after that can you help
the other question in terms of
accessibility to the health center
we can't obtain that information on the
freight again I think this is a link
with Hadley health center the box for
group practice through local knowledge I
can't give that answers though I'm
afraid thank you well I think we're all
aware of the pressures on the health
servers on doctors
on schools and what have you so I think
you'll have to weigh that up members
yourselves any other comments councillor
Hinton Thank You mr. chairman
been looking at the provisions of CS 11
nights mostly except boxford's a core
village and therefore the hinterland
criteria do not apply looking at the
locally identified need for housing and
employment and specific local needs such
as affordable housing and local
identified community needs have we seen
any of that for this application and
where is the employment I noted say it
states in the report that there will be
some employment during the construction
phase but for whom is there a sudden
influx of building workers in boxford
who suddenly need employment no they
will be coming in from ground and about
the the area probably the county even so
we'll end up with a lot of traffic once
repeat the homes are built and occupied
where are those people going to work not
in Botsford cuz nobody supplying any
employment in Botsford so they get to
get in the car and go somewhere else now
we've had motions before full council to
declare climate emergencies and to
develop a climate responsible action and
the government's even talking about zero
carbon by 2050 we're never going to get
to it if we keep building in the middle
of the countryside with no employment
and no sustainable activity within those
villages people are going to have to get
in a car and go so where is the
employment provision from this
application and also the locally
identified community indeed as it states
in CS eleven
I have a health center are the first
boss and will do the health yes the
website wasn't working it's given it
doesn't break down between box with and
hardly unfortunate it's just it's called
the hair had leave Oxford group practice
so that isn't 100% helpful but the it
does confirm provided you live in the
practice here you are able to register
at the practice so you may register at
the Hadley and Boxford group not
specifically just box it thank you know
the question the question to your if it
was on jobs and workers and future of
course thank you chair and I think in
terms of the economic gain certainly
during the build phase there would been
influx of of development and indeed jobs
created as a result of the proposal the
spending power that goes with that not
just at the time of development but also
from residents of the site upon the
village is going to be a benefit
certainly for the local economy
the new Anglia strategic economic plan
acknowledges that there would be support
created from one point five jobs to
every increase so in effect creating
jobs through development would have a
knock-on effect locally and that can
only be a benefit I think in terms of
employment people need places yes to
work and certainly providing homes where
people can live would help assist with
that so there's no reason to believe
that it would not enable assessment for
residents who wish to work nearby
now economic provision is provided in
terms of the employment side that would
be limited I think in terms of what the
site delivers as a whole once built out
because employment is not part of the
proposal so that's all that I can really
say on on that aspect and I trust that
you'll consider the spending power that
is engaged in terms of the affordable
we've spoken about that at length that
is a community benefit in a way in terms
of community benefits such as a building
that's not part of the proposal I'm
afraid
I think what we need to look at is
whether is within context of CS 11 and
your officers consider that it is with
regards to the needs of the village both
locally and in terms of the district
wide there was a local housing needs
assessment submitted that does
adequately following provision and I
believe cancer Horan's confirm that
there is surplus need so there is a
deficit that this game would fill partly
so I think we need to consider that both
from the Affordable 's and from the
economic improvement locally thank you
okay cancel about it
thank you I'd like to talk about
employment opportunities locally because
it's it's very interesting that in very
near vicinity two Boxford you've got
koenings fruit operation which employs
90 people we've only just approved a
change to their their planning so we are
all quite familiar with that that site
and what jobs are on offer and so that's
very viable for the houses on this side
of box but they're even closer there's
also the golf
stopa Island Hotel that I think mr.
bring you attended a meeting with me and
with the hotel recently didn't we and we
heard about their their plans to and
their actual needs are for about 500
employees in total across all their
businesses and and in fact they do have
problems recruiting because the lack of
housing and that was actually raised
with us as counselors in this ward only
this year so yeah I'm quite I'm quite
you know passionate about this because I
think there is there is a very real
employment prospects very near to this
side thank you
any other comments members canceller
Parker Thank You Jett okay so one item
that we haven't touched upon yet which
for me is absolutely fundamental and
that is the the apparent contradiction
between the recommendation in the
proposal in the application but our own
planning policy officers objection and
that that it you know concerns me
greatly that we you know there doesn't
seem to have been any mention of it and
actually our own planning policy is
quite scathing of this proposal you know
the very last line says it is unclear
how deliverable the site will actually
be and that the site is speculative and
no certainty of likely annual build-out
of Rights Botsford is not the most
sustainable so such settlement when
considered as a geographical hole across
the district for for major growth so I
mean the paragraph is on page nine and
over on page ten so we we have you know
we have a planning policy team who write
the very policies that we use to
determine our own applications who is
opposed to this application can I have
some and I've got a secondary question
after I've had this response if that's
all right Jeff thank you thank you
councillor Parker I think the policy
comments expressed are in mind in terms
of our overall balance we have to
recognize the policy that is engaged and
that he says - there's going to be
conflict with says - naturally because
the development is technically located
in the countryside so there'll always be
a degree of conflict in that regard and
that's heightened by the land supply
position so officers do recognize that
we also have CS 11 edge of settlement
subject to the criteria test which we've
been
and officers consider that it is
acceptable is material now if I may I'd
like to go through a couple of aspects
that are mentioned here because it's
been broken down into what is
essentially three paragraphs by the
planning policy officer in relation to
connectivity and poor access to service
and facilities which is in the first
paragraph your officers consider that
you can walk to the center of the
village there's good footpath provision
a few lines down it states no pedestrian
footpath along Sand Hill your officers
consider that there is both in terms of
existing and what is proposed through
the section 106 to be linked up that
paragraph is summarized this would need
further advice from the Highways
Authority we've been to the Highways
Authority and discussed it with them
they raised no objection the next
paragraph
boxford is not the most sustainable
assessment when considered as a
geographical hold sorry you've already
cited that that line your officers do
agree in a sense when you consider it
against towns such as Sudbury or Hadley
it's on the next peg down sequentially
ideally we develop in towns Sudbury
badly as a as a policy measure the next
peg down is core villages for which
Boxford is one then its hinterland and
so on sequential preference so we have
considered that and in terms of you know
whether it would require you know future
occupiers to travel by car there are
services and facilities available there
are bus links residents would have the
option and that's what we are providing
so I'll leave you to draw your own
conclusions on that and so I won't bore
you much longer
the advice taken with regards to the
ecology is also material as is the flood
and water comments no objections have
been raised with regards to ecology or
flood and water and it is considered
deliverability we've taken the
opportunity to impose an 18-month
time limit on the reserved amount of
submission so we as officers would one
submission of reserved matters within 18
months typically we go with 3 years but
this is deliverable and there's a proven
track-record through the agent that's
demonstrated in their planning statement
that outlines the deliverability
of the company and also the site and
that's why we've imposed an 18-month
condition thank you once again caves
park is giving you a full answer there
which hopefully is helpful and to
members any other you've got a second
question or has he picked it out well I
would ask it share all the same I mean
it was it was mentioned and that's just
with regards to the again our planning
officer team saying there is surface
water flooding towards the northern part
of the site which is appears to be
contradictory to paragraph 14 on page 27
that says the site is not located in a
vulnerable flood zone area therefore the
risk of flooding is considered to be low
so there appears to be a contradiction
there we'll get you an answer councillor
Parker thank you for your question so in
essence the flood zone is depicted by
the blue extend the site is not located
in a concerning flood zone flood zone
two or three the site is not so
susceptible to flood risk when it you
compare it against the Environment
Agency modelling nonetheless this does
not negate the need to provide surface
water drainage provision infiltration
tests have been carried out the site is
readily capable of accommodating the
flood drainage and measures required and
there's lots of different modern
techniques used so there's no reason to
believe that a site could not come
forward with adequate drainage provision
remember the indicative layout which I
should have somewhere shows a basin this
is indicative so if it was to be cited
elsewhere we would deal with us at
reserve matters but again it's a
worthwhile point that
our trust is clear thank you thanks
remembers any new points or questions
perhaps I could suggest that we vote on
approval of the application I'm glad you
put the words there rather than MIDI
thank you would you like to start again
I suggest that we approve this
application for outline planning
provision yeah I'm that's in accordance
of the officers recommendation and we
didn't we have not had any additional
conditions suggested during the debate
I've not noted any
let me be clear are you proposing that
we accept the officers recommendation
that's detailed in front of us on our
papers yes I am thank you do I have a
seconder for that
hence cancelled Osborne do you wish to
make any comment yeah Thank You mr.
chairman
yes I I gradually second this
application as per the officers
recommendation I do understand the
position within the traffic congestion
in in Swan Street when that application
that particularly careful coming forward
I was against it so but I cannot see any
reason for that if if the highways are
going to intend to do further works just
in front of Swan Street and possibly do
something we suppose three thank you
thank you now remember the less there's
any new questions or factors that you
want brought up I'm going to put this to
the members nope
right I've had a recommendation from
councillor Barrett seconded by
Councillor Osborne to accept the
officers recommendations as outlined in
your papers for approval all those in
favor please show those against that is
lost so I now have to ask those members
if they've got a proposal for refusal to
put it clear what everyone in the room
cuz this the gang we've got people who
may not be familiar with the planning
process what the vote that we've had
just means there is no authority to get
permission if members wish to refuse
then there must be a proposal to refuse
with with reasons for refusal laughter
do you have a proposal for refusal with
reasons please
failure to give me one I will use my
powers to defer it and then so right
good councillor Parker right super job
chair so we're back back here again
aren't we and this is relates back to
what I was saying earlier about you know
a little bit of arm at the back
unfortunately because we now have two we
now have to find a comprehensive
planning reason to to refuse but I think
it's there
yeah absolutely so I do think it's there
for me I've just
it is a finely balanced application this
and and I do acknowledge that you know
no that's always the problem in a
committee situation you've got to make a
you know a decision ultimately at the
end and you've got to think fast on your
feet sometimes but for me there are
still there's just too many question
marks around this application chair to
be honest that haven't been squared away
so for me I think the school's issue is
a major
so you know we're talking about
infrastructure there etc anyway I'm sort
of filling time hoping that my
colleagues are man fully looking through
the policy push you for your research I
so chair I would like to propose refusal
of the officers recommendation on policy
basis CS two CS and CS 15 I don't know
if any of my CS 15 obviously the policy
states that the applications or any
application must respect the landscape
landscape features streetscape etc so I
don't believe that it does that does it
make a positive contribution to local
local character paragraph three protects
or create jobs and sites to strengthen
or diversify the local economy it
doesn't evidence that paragraph four
ensure and I think that's a key word
ensure an appropriate level of services
for facilities and infrastructure
it doesn't seek to do that well yeah I'm
off and running now here we've got
paragraphs three and four with you there
right carry on I would say paragraph
five in terms of enhancing local
services and facilities and indeed rural
communities because coming back to the
school's aspect there is there is a
knock-on effect for rural communities
outside so paragraph five paragraph
paragraph eight potentially as well
address this climate change through
design adaptation well we don't know
because of course it's not but paragraph
eight potentially
we've got CS 11 CS 2 cs50 n-- which was
landscape paragraphs 3 4 and file you've
far even was local services I've
forgotten what 3 & 4 was but the
officers will find they're buried and
you're using paragraph 8 as backup so
those would be my reasons for refusal of
the officers recommendation yeah thank
you thank you that's very helpful very
helpful if you've got all of them down
did you wish to comment on any could you
confirm so yeah could you confirm so cs2
as in the broad principle that being
outside of built up a pair of boundary
and then CS 11 I think you said 5 which
is community community needs is that
right okay you did you mention CS 1 as
well which is the landscape character
etc yeah it sort of just duplicated it
we're told it's point one of CSS here
7.1 yeah which would take a gs-15 is
that right well there's some specific
paragraphs in CS 15 counselor that you
were considering beside the landscape
one which is converse yes sir I'm not
entirely sure the question chair because
I've just listed all of the all of the
relative if you could clarify the the
limb of CS 15 that you feel the
application should be refused for just
so we're clear of the reason
[Applause]
a lot came through counselors just to
check we've got recorded it properly I'm
sure they always say if we could just be
sure in that case chair can we do it the
other way around and you just repeat
back what what I said in that case and
then I think Larry know tell us what
we've got
so we've got CS - yep CS 11 limb 1 and
limb 5 in terms of community needs and
Vance gay porno 2 strikes
and I think that was it and four so
limbs one four and five of CS 11 how
long we've see as tyr's mentioned I
believe that's it that's the last series
15 as well yeah okay so if I could you
want me to reel off well I think I
recorded three four five and eight was
it paragraph C at three four five minute
that's correct I did put two in there as
well power - in CS 15 as well - of cs50
cs50.tv all right we're just going to
read these out so that we're sure
Chancellor Parker can you just read out
what you've got there okay so we have CS
2 CSL Evan paragraphs or limbs one five
and four and five one four and five and
six 15 we have two three four five and
eight
just to be clear to members of the
public so that you're not totally
confused the reason that we've had to
insist from councillor Parker to put
forward the reasons for his refusal
which I'll take a photon in a moment is
that if he's successful in there then
these are the arguments that the
officers feel they can argue if the
applicant takes us to a meal so that is
why we have to be clear on it and that's
the strongest ones that cancel apart for
confining in the policies in front
counter it's a bit tight it's a little
tedious but I could just just let people
know what those cover so I'm on CS 15 so
I'll start there and you site is to
which is making a possible positive
contribution to local character 3 which
is protect or create jobs to strengthen
or diversify the local economy you're
saying it would fail on that 4 which is
ensure an appropriate level of services
etc a 5 which is retained protect or
enhanced local services and then eight
which is address climate change I think
of those if I may say four and I
wouldn't hang the school thing of that
the County Council has statute provider
of education hasn't gotten an objection
to what's been proposed there's a
solution there to that there would be
places in in time and boxwood school and
certainly other surrounding scores so so
if we are going before I would I would
ask that that didn't include any
reference to schooling mr. chairman if I
could initiate there the only problem
with that of course is it then effect
really makes the paragraph fake we're
addressing climate change etc
contradictory to the to the school's one
because they're gonna bust them to
somewhere else which is
good point yeah I don't want to become
involved in a debate because omble -
you're the elected members but I think
obviously that the narrative within the
report was that there are some some
children outs outside of Boxford who go
to the school and over time they would
be displaced by local children so it may
be argued that there would be less
travelled
we don't know you want to keep that in
an art I think that's the bottom line
chairman balance yes I would like to
keep it in yes thank you so that was CS
15 I'll now go to see us 11 just to
confirm that we're talking about the the
right paragraphs there this is just so
that we know what we're saying in the
case of an appeal so we're exactly clear
if it does help
okay so CS 11 paragraph 1 refers to
landscape environmental and heritage
characteristics or the village so that's
that's clear enough
five oh sorry for because we put wrong
for is locally identified need housing
and employment and specific local needs
such as affordable housing I've given an
answer on that that there is a mechanism
for the affordable to be focused on the
the cluster I just have to make that
point again events still wish to go with
that reason then so be it do you wish to
keep that one in Chancellor powerful
I'll take the offices advices on that
one chair I'll accept what the office is
saying on that one so we removed that
one okay carry on mr. chairman the only
bit that the officer is saying is
perhaps weak on that particular point
it's the affordable housing what about
the open market housing and the
employment which it's an integral part
of that that's correct it's the element
related to affordable housing I think if
if and when we craft the refusal would
have to make sure we're not saying that
daily refers to the affordable housing
it was very far I meant to gather
stronger case as we can get forward you
know and the last point was locally
identified community needs you're happy
with that yeah and you're happy with all
them okay good right I think we got to
the situation where I can now put this
which I'm good to do which I can now go
for a second time you've heard of the
reasons put forward by councilor Park
I've got them wrote down do I have a
seconder for that councillor Hinton so
you wish to make comment only on that I
think has been said mr. chairman thank
you good I have to ask is there any
other new relevant points anybody wish
to bring up at this stage no I have a
proposal for refusal proposed by
councillor Parker seconded by Councillor
Hinton all those in favor of refused and
this item 6a please show those against
that is carried this item is refused
members will have a ten minute break
Comfort great please be back by two
twenty two twelve
you
and we're on page 37
and it Elizabeth
Clarkson case officer thank you
so this is an application and outline
application for twenty-five Wellings
with layout and access sort at this time
so this is the site as you can see it's
the entire edge of the field you just
see so this is the existing 1970s wheat
field estates the built-up area boundary
at the moment goes along the edge of the
road long wheat fields here the other
thing you you won't quite see on this
map but just beyond here is the grade 2
listed that Arnold's Hall and you should
also note the school and the village
hall are in this location here again the
aerial photograph in your report you'll
note that there was an application in -
2015 for slightly smaller scheme and
this was located in this of the top half
of the site up here was for 15 dwellings
up here you'll also know on here the
existing estate and then leading onto
the rest of the religion on what Field
Road and on the school and the village
hall in this location okay so key issues
are relating to policy which the key
policies are CS to CS and CS 15 which
will all be familiar with and the
paragraphs 3.14 to 3.39 set out the
compliance with CS 11 within your report
you will note that
local needs a Housing Survey has been
done and it did consider that there was
some need for for more housing within
the village second key issue is the
issue of sustainability what field has
limited services within the village it's
got a primary school a village hall and
some churches but there is no shops or
employment land so it is heavily reliant
on private vehicles and it is considered
as an unsustainable location third key
issue is the impact of the character of
the village and countryside there is
some impact on the lawn on the landscape
though it is considered that there are
some benefits also in terms of providing
some increased landscaping but overall
it's considered that the dis benefits of
bringing out bringing more development
along the edge of the village discounts
any potential benefits of a better
landscaping scheme and you'll see that
in the in the photos and then the third
issue is related to the foot way
proposals for the village school and
I'll point that out on on the
photographs and just so you're aware in
the lake papers there's a couple of
things from flooding so the applicant
has provided a bit more information on
why they can't do a full such system and
our flood and how food and water
management officer has come back to say
it's up to the planning authority to
decide if the viability statement is
provided does provide sufficient reason
for the hybrid suds it's my opinion that
it does and therefore we're not looking
at a another reason for refusal that it
isn't a full sod system so this is the
site layout
proposing 25 dwellings with eight up
here as i8 affordable in two locations
up here and up here and it's quite a
low-density scheme with plenty of
landscaping and the applicant has agreed
that if you were minded to approve it
they would be happy to approve the the
schedule of of housing so that the
numbers in terms of house numbers house
sizes could be agreed at this point and
you'll also notice the proposed boundary
treatment to the edge of the field here
again this just provides a bit more
information on the proposed landscaping
so you can see that there is some
existing landscaping in this location
already which you saw on site and it's
proposed to increase the landscaping
along here but also to put in a thick
boundary hedge and some mature some
trees along this boundary and there's
also there's also some landscaping at
the front in line with the existing
landscape thing which is on that corner
of the field as it is and you'll see
that you'll note the roads in and out so
it's proposing various roads in and then
sort of pedestrian access between and
also an access along here for
pedestrians to this footpath up here
okay so it's not particularly clear but
this this is to provide the indicative
boundary elevations to give you an idea
of how the landscaping would would
change so at the moment this is the
existing wheat fields site so you can
see that there are some trees but it's
not heavily landscaped and the proposal
is to obviously put the new development
in but then have more landscaping on the
edge of the field boundary clearly some
of this will take time to mature so the
larger trees would take time to mature
okay so these are the existing
photographs so this is from wheat fields
looking into the site so as you saw on
site it's approximately half this this
field would be developed so around here
and again this is looking the other
direction so Bernard Hall is here and
then the development would sort of come
just before these buildings in a line
here so again about half the feel a bit
less again looking back again another
photo from wheat fields so this existing
landscaping would be retained and
improved and this would be sort of as a
edge and then they'll be the housing and
their more landscaping again so this is
coming this is showing it from what
field road so the villages that way so
as you can see you can see parts of
wheat fields but sort of the further you
get from the village the less abrasive
it is and there is already some mature
part planting on the edge so it's not
completely terrible what the existing
situation is again you can see that's
wheat fields there with some some
landscaping in front so this is just to
explain the footway proposal so as part
of this application the parish sorry the
highway authority has requested that a
new foot way is put in to the village
school which is just here the entrance
is just here so that would go around
there and and then meet the main
pavement on what Field Road so that
would be considered a benefit of the
scheme so
so in conclusion the applicator the
recommendation is to refuse I set out on
page 54 of your report it's considered
that there it's an unsustainable
location which will be highly dependent
on private vehicles and that there is
some landscaping harm due to the loss of
open content character and rural setting
thank you thank you
remembers of the public pleasant for the
this one mobile Robeson I'd like to come
forward sir you have three minutes in
which to address the committee you can
stand or sit perhaps should remain there
at the end of our service any questions
for you thank you can you put the mic on
yes good morning I'm here on behalf of
the parish council and I'm a resident of
what field the parish would like to
express their appreciation that the
planning officers have visited visited
the site and recommend that the
application should be rejected we concur
with this recommendation as the
strategic planning team acknowledged the
proposal would disproportionately expand
a rural settlement where sustainability
and infrastructure is poor and a major
proposal would exacerbate that situation
Beiber's recent planning Housing Policy
states a five-year supply has already
been identified babies emerging local
plan identifies a single new dwelling
over the same period for what field so
this proposal is indirect and material
contradiction to Beiber's own
independent assessment the committee
report refers to what field
neighbourhood plan process which whilst
would not yet complete we do feel should
be considered based on the provision
analysis of residents questionnaire we
believe we can state that this proposal
would overwhelmingly be against the
Democratic wishes of the village the
parish questions the applicants timing
of their application in relation to the
perceived outcome of the neighbourhood
plan in that it is in an attempt to
circumvent parish scrutiny moreover it
should not be overlooked that a previous
application on this site has been
refused by the Committee on grounds of
unjustified and sustainable development
we also think it worth emphasizing that
due to poor bus services amenities and
employment opportunities there is a very
high level of car dependency in the
village so increased numbers would
increase traffic and hen heart in and
hence harm to the environment finally
there are a number of loose ends the
applicant has failed to address the
flood and water assessment has not been
resolved there is no submitted evidence
that substantiates the demand or need
for additional housing the issue of
sustainable school numbers has been
raised our belief is that irrespective a
development the school's excellent
reputation and good Ofsted rating means
the school will always be at or near
capacity new development will not change
the dynamics of this Thank You members
have you any questions for the last
speaker no thank you very much
thank you
anything you wish to comment what you
just had the anger the water only that
at the moment we have to give the the
neighborhood plan very limited way
because it's it's in very early stages
we have an objector mr. Roy so you also
have three minutes in which to address
the committee that should remain at the
end of it and I'll service any questions
for you ready
good morning I believe you still good
morning just thank you for this
opportunity for me to express the views
of the villages of clearly laid out
their concerns and I reflected and
summarized on page 44 of the proud and
officers report in addition to our
listed concerns reflected in the 43
objections I would like to cover the
following points bailiff has identified
that there is no urgent need for
additional housing and that they do not
have a house in shortfall and the fact
they are benefiting from having a five
year lam position this is also reflected
in the office of report on pages 45 and
53 there is no evidence supporting this
development would address a shortfall as
Bayboro stated they do not have a
shortfall in addition to this
development we have an impact on the
village is very limited amenities in
fact we feel it will have an opposite
struggle negative impact this
development will have an environmental
impact and will cause significant
increase in car usage within the village
area what field has a very limited bus
service which would not service any
commuter requirements at all in addition
to the bus service this may well be
under threat in the near future the
remote location of what field will
require a personal transport to get to
and from one maintained amenities and
services to places of work and
employment there is no employment
opportunities in what field
this view is is also concluded and in
the officers report and is highlighted
as remote from local services remote
from transport modes to scale a location
at this development will cause harm to
the landscape of the village and will
not blend or merge with the existing
village layer nor the existing village
envelope finally we filled at the
position of this development will not
allow cohesion within the village and
will put a strain on the close-knit
community spirit still found in what
what field village we fully support the
officers recommendations to refuse this
application a gang thank you for the
time members any questions you wish to
put to the speaker cancel about it thank
you
I probably should have asked this the
last speaker but as you live in the
village it might be you might not be
able to tell me and does the village
have good broadband connection
definitely no I think there
any other questions members Chancellor
is um I used to travel through there a
lot my children used to go to school
there do you still have a village shop
thank you thank you
any other questions Chancellor parrot
lingered over there you saw me
um I think was mentioned there is a
preschool though is there yes there is a
skull it's very small it's about 50
places no sorry no I don't know there's
no preschool I think I heard no can you
turn your mic off thank you
any other questions No thank you very
much it's anything thank you we'll move
on we have the applicant agent Phillip
instant who sir I think though the
procedure but I will just remind you of
three minutes you can sit or stand and
then I'll send us any questions at the
end of a folio thank you good morning
chairman and councillors I'm here today
to speak in support of the application
for a resident residential development
for 25 drillings including eight
affordable units the proposals before
you have evolved over some time with
early scheme being presented to the
residents of the parish council back in
2018 as the officers recommend report
notes the site falls outside the
built-up area boundary of the village
however does abut it and there is little
or no opportunity for the village to
grow further within the village envelope
the proposal consists of a mix of two
three and four bedroom houses and
bungalows
and purposely excludes any large four
and five bedroom properties in in the
view of providing suitable housing to
deal with a local and district need the
application is an outline form however
we have openly discussed with the case
officer applying a planning condition to
enforce the proposed mix this type and
size of housing will aid to support the
village to provide smaller starter homes
for younger residents who wish to remain
in the village and for elder residents
to downsize and release further housing
stock I appreciate that the case
officers concluded the site is
unsustainable however I believe that
hinterland villages such as watch what
field can absorb a certain level of
development and that is important to
extend existing communities the
development of this nature with smaller
family homes will also support what
field village school with local children
attending their local school this sort
support will be extended by providing a
footpath link from the school as viewed
at a recent committee site visit the
applicant has already agreed for this
with a planning officer that it will be
funded by the development I would also
like to recall the committee decision
made in 2018 against offers of
recommendation on sustainability grounds
for the land east of King George is
playing field in radan where the
committee commented that baby district
council is a rural district and that not
all journeys can be made without the use
of a motor vehicle and approved 24
dwellings which are currently under
construction that leads me into the
deliverability of the site the site is
relatively small only
801 point 8 4 hectares in area and in a
single ownership most vehicle axis lead
directly onto an adopted highway with no
ramps and strips and good safe village
visibility I can confirm the applicant
is already in discussion with a local
quality developer with experience in the
village completing the successful Church
farm sized sites last year in conclusion
councillors I ask you to consider the
development put before you and judge the
obvious planning gains
of appropriate affordable and market
housing support to the village school
and the benefits to the village
community and balance these with the
offices recommendation
thank you for your time thank you very
much members do you have any questions
the last speaker Chancellor Parker yeah
I think you just like to ask what what
engagement you've undertaken with the
with the parish council and respectively
the application we originally met with
parish council about 18 months ago and
said we would like to present our
proposal to them and within probably a
six month period we actually had a
public presentation in the village hall
and lots of visitors and took on board
comments interested to what people have
said and then progressed are asking from
there
yes good morning Philip um have you
taken any steps or if engagement to
ensure that the eight affordable homes
actually go to what field or local
people we haven't at this stage we
haven't but that's something that we're
might you know most happy to do as part
of the 106 - to enforce that is the case
yeah that's not a problem the landowner
is is relatively local and would want to
see that happen and was you know
involved in previous generations were
involved in the wheat fields development
so it's something that they would be
pleased to do yeah and actually the
developer that is potentially interested
is already it was developing a trade and
they've just actually favor of just
purchased their their affordable housing
in the road and development so that
could be something that any other
questions no thank you very much right
the local board member
Chancellor Jemison is a member of the
Planning Committee and he's chosen to
take part in the meeting so I'll go
straight to you first
we're now in open debate okay thank you
Jeff as I know abilities do need to grow
and what field
talking to the residents and not against
developments per se and they have I
believe on - partly neighbourhood plan
identified some areas within the boot
about area boundary for potential
development in the future overlooking my
concerns are pretty much already been
highlighted by the residents end and the
planning officer the fact this village
is wood you saw yourself with me on the
site was it's only a small village
there's no infrastructure no shops no
doctors etc the school suffer Kent
County I believe that said there are no
places in the foreseeable future
for new capacity now
the bus services has been pointed out
are are very limited and is one one bus
a day at the moment - on a Thursday
Monday to Friday they're gonna be under
threat in the March so these things I
mean these are concerned with this
development which is or potentially be a
16% increase on the size of the village
Wow
not particularly again you know I want
to be open minded about the I mean I do
worry that such an increase would put a
lot of pressure on this village and also
it also is putting that by the planning
officer be predominantly relying on
vehicle traffic there is the council
we've just declared climate emergency
and biodiversity emergency yesterday and
we well 25 houses potentially 50 cars
lots more vehicle movement let's worry
that Skinner put a dent in our climate
emergency targets this yes my concerns
at these any comments you of that
nothing coming forward I will move from
the chair the officers recommendation
for refused or do I have a seconder
obviously wasn't paired attention at
that moment I withdraw that and lay the
debate to continues please be more alert
sorry sorry check a major part of the
recommendation for refusal stems on the
sustainability of the location so I
really want to challenge that because I
think that's based on quite outdated
ideas about what is what is achievable
in the rural area so many of our
applications are based in rural areas
and we have to really accept that
services don't survive in these sort of
locations like shops and and so on so
many people use their supermarket's home
delivery or leaving the village anyway
and so not necessarily generating extra
journeys by not having a local shop so
one point also we're moving into an era
where we are going to have more electric
cars and there's quite a quite a big
move politically to encourage more
electric vehicles I think you'd accept
now it's very much on the agenda and I
think we are gonna see a major change in
in that in the future also on on the
school as I've said previously these
village schools are vulnerable to lower
school places and it's only got five
fifty five attending the school at the
moment with quite a large cohort leaving
either last summer or this year I'm not
sure from the report but when that
happens you know they might have a lot
of places the moment but each year
they've got to they've got that pressure
to fill new places because the pupils
move up the school all the time so it's
never static like that and they are
incredibly vulnerable to an teacher on
the edge of viability themselves by
having concerns about new pupils coming
forward and if these villages are
allowed to just not have a new
development put in place they the this
this school becomes one of those things
that is is at risk of closure as we've
seen in monks II Leone
couple of years ago when you know
parents will be concerned if there's
only four children in their schools in
their child's year group do they really
want the child to attend to school like
that when they've got so limited
opportunities for friendship groups so I
think all these villages do vite
absolutely need some development you've
got you've already got the adjacent
wheat fields and I don't know how all of
that how long that's been built but what
normally happens with with those
developments is that the families moving
with young children they grow up they go
through this the different age range at
the school and then they come out and so
then you kind of need a new a new supply
of younger younger families also the
these villages they they are so
expensive people who've grown up in
those villages to live in so having a
new supply of affordable houses is a
credibly attractive option for the
school and for the village so I know
it's recommend refusal but I think some
of that is built on on really the wrong
premise and I want to challenge that I
think we've seen some of the
demonstration you've shown us about the
impact on the landscape I think like
many of these areas we we have to
consider the addition of landscaping and
softening of those can improve the
impact on the landscape significantly as
we saw on the photographs showing wheat
fields that doesn't impact very heavily
on the the local landscape so there's no
reason why this should not have the same
in in a number of years so III I can't
accept the recommendation of refusal I'd
like to hear more debate first thank you
very much you put for Kairos a pile of
pints there can you pick some of those
up Elizabeth and in relation to the
school there has been so the last the
year who's just left now last year's
year six they had ten pupils and in
reception this year is nine pupils so
the county council have looked at this
and they are not it is a small school
it's only got a nine per year and it's
always been historically small but
they're not concerned about particularly
about falling numbers they feel that
it's sustainable in this you know of
nine a year going forward and also the
school allowing new housing it's not
necessarily going to help the school
because obviously our parents have
preference school preference and some
parents will decide to you know go to a
different school so there are children
in that village who don't go to the
school and equally there were children
who were brought into the village
because they want them to go to a small
school so there isn't necessarily that
connection
thank you any other comments questions
from an employment point of view a lot
of people do work at home now and rely
on broadband connection to be able to do
that so the rural nature and the
isolated nature is perhaps less less
significant if they are doing that could
there be anything in SIL to achieve
better better connection for the village
or is it actually planned it Suffolk
County Council planning some
improvements there
well Suffolk County Council is rolling
out an ambitious program of bringing
broadband to suffer but I don't know
quite what it is at the Fox 4 sorry I
don't know sorry boss Watford area can
you help us I can't no I mean I don't
know I mean obviously the the local
representative said that the broadband
was poor and we haven't had a lot of
objections based on broadband where
other places where it is incredibly poor
we have had a lot of people say you know
there aren't those facilities so I don't
know whether it's any worse than any
other rural areas we've been favor
Chancellor Tamsin do you any idea but
the cards give you that full out sort of
aid but I know throughout the county of
Suffolk Suffolk County Council was
trying to to get as full of coverage as
possible hmm but there are some little
black areas I'm afraid yeah
any other questions comments no nothing
coming forward Chancellor I was born yes
thank you Miss cheering just a few
comments I mean when we were on the site
visit I heard some news what not news
but going back in time with what field
the anglo-saxon set up that was was
there which I was very impressed with
however what I would say is that that
the chances of a village actually going
down and therefore known young people in
their accounts of barrenness spoken
about
obviously is a big issue however I'm
sure that if there were further issues
in what field we would have heard it
today from the parish hand and the
objector so therefore I'm afraid as the
reef officers refusal recommendation is
for refusal I'm afraid it's very little
that we can do about that
although I am very disturbed to hear the
position of what feelings in terms of
the amount of people are in their
residents that are actually there thank
you
right you leave it I have no choice
members but to put forward the officers
recommendation as laid out on your page
and for you for Ritu so do I have a
seconder Thank You councillor plum I did
see your hand go up eventually but I'd
already start as I was going to finish
did you wish to comment okay its
proposed and seconded that we move the
officers recommendation for refusal as
set out in your papers all those in
favor please show those against
those members of a planning committee
are put in here to make decisions not to
sit on fences but anyway that's my
opinion I've said it is there any
abstentions thank you we'll move on we
have the next one which is page 57 we're
still up what field members
the case officer for this one is Daniel
Cameron okay Daniel over to you
Thank You chair okay thank you
Thank You chair Thank You members yes so
remaining in what field for the time
being
we've got an application before us in
outline for 15 dwellings six of which
will be affordable with all matters is
reserved safer access here is a site we
have what field road running along the
south we have Norton Road running along
here we've got a strip of linear
development along the northwest side
there we've got the church church field
Church Lane development here and then we
have the rest of what field down here
just in terms of constraints members
you'll see but within the cordon
sanitaire that relates to the sewage
treatment works down here we've had
representations from ambient water who
operate and responsible for sewage
treatment works and they've not objected
to the principle of development within
this area indeed if you look at the
cordon you see that quite a lot of what
feel does exist generally now would fall
within it we've also got the listed
building up here that's what field Hall
it's great to listed there's also just
off picture and a street farmhouse which
is on the run of what Field Road as it
comes down here a little way to the
south of the site in consulting with
colleagues from heritage they haven't
they haven't found it necessary to
comment on this application due to the
degree of separation between this site
and the listed buildings in terms of
other constraints the the sort of a
green shading across this entire map is
the wall Ocean airfield safeguarding
area we're dealing with residential
development here members so we have
existing two-story development along in
this area obviously we're dealing with
an outline application so design
appearance layout would all be reserved
matters
so we'd have additional consultation
from them should you be minded to
when the application comes back at that
stage the other thing to know and it's
apologies numbers it's not shown very
well on this map but there is sort of a
vague red oisin as well that just
denotes that were inside the impact area
on to triple s eyes or sites of Special
Scientific Interest and those are onset
woods which is some way to the east and
then wolves would which is sort of
southeast off off the bypass that oddly
key issues are similar to the previous
application before members we have the
policy context out for you at section 3
of the report we have the sustainability
issues with regards to the three strands
running through the NPP F the social the
economic and the environmental we have
the impact on the character of the
village you'll see from the existing
areas and when I bring latest lines up
that what field at this point is
generally quite linear yes we have some
estate of Allen in a wheat fields that
we've just looked at and also the Church
Lane development and then there's also
an issue of footpath so my colleague
previously touched upon and we'll go
over that as well just with regard to
late representations we did have
additional surveys carried out in the
form of a great question each survey and
a report on biodiversity enhancement
within the site specifically aimed at
breeding birds
those have been received and sent to our
ecology consultants at play services and
they've removed they're holding
injection reported in there in the
report and are now not listening
objection subject to securing the
ecological mitigation in biodiversity
enhancement contained within the report
so if numbers should be minded to
approve the application we should be
looking to condition that that is
included as well coming back up to the
aerial map again you'll know the linear
amount of development along here and
there's a small and call this active
element but the rest of field is largely
linear along this run
a hopfield road here we have the layout
obviously this is a outline with many
motors reserved the only issue for
consideration by members at the moment
is this access point here onto Norton
Road that would be unchanged as the
application came back if you reminder to
approve members we just created an
overlay to show the site layer in
context there we've got this existing
agricultural field bounded on all sides
by existing hedgerow mature tree
planting we're taking a corner of it the
agricultural field is grade 3 land as
was the previous application I believe
and we're just showing there the
arrangement as indicated on the
indicative plans within that so you can
see the relationship between the rest of
what field and this application we have
got an indicative landscape plant
submitted with 3 and application
it shows retention of boundary landscape
treatment to this side the bottom of the
site and then introduction of a new belt
of planting up here to avoid a barrier
to the rest of the agricultural science
so the rest of the field would remain in
agricultural use as it currently is if
we move on to the site photos I'll
record numbers and would have had a site
visit here so should hopefully be
familiar with the site this is at the
access point to the site this is looking
back into what field they know a lack of
sort of pavement and foot way connecting
into the rest of the village from this
point numbers it's 750 meters to the
school the location obviously is as you
you saw in the last term officers report
there's good visibility splay shown from
this point and then if we jump ahead we
can see the linear run of development
upon the left-hand side of the screen
then there's the existing hedgerow along
the frontage again there's a good degree
of visibility but again noting no foot
connection up the rest of the village if
we come now this is the access point and
we're looking into the site so this is
the portion of the site that would
remain agricultural land and will be
accessed elsewhere and then this is the
other aspect of the site that would be
so we have the existing boundary
planting that be retained along here and
here and then this is part of the site
that would form the access and then be
laid out for members the recommendation
before members is for refusal of the
application for similar reasons to the
previous application in terms of social
and economic sustainability while there
is some benefit the benefit is limited
in terms of environmental there is some
enhancement of biodiversity the Sun
mitigation of impacts to have some
positive way to attribute here but in
terms of connectivity both within the
village and within the wider district
officers consider the site would be
largely dependent on private car
transport to meet the needs of the
residents and have therefore found that
when judged against all three strands
together the site would fail the
sustainability test I set out with it
thank you
we have members of the public here
parish council David Dre we've heard the
procedures I don't need to go through I
should remain seated at the end of the
three minutes thank you right good
morning and can I thank you for taking
the trouble to come and see our site and
walk it and survive it without body
armor or any other natural protection
but it meant that you could see for
yourself the reality and I would like to
thank Mr Cameron for the thoroughness of
his rather damning report on what we see
as something which is being sneaked
under the wire while we are trying to
develop our neighborhood plan that has
been pushed through very quickly and
with some very poorly thought through
ideas it has been criticized even by
highways and their plan to build a
footpath that is supposedly going to
connect through the village it's
impossible it's not thought through
thoroughly problems start to develop
very quickly when you look at it the
housing stock anyway
in beta we know is sufficient for five
years there is no requirement on the
outskirts of our village in open fields
to start building more homes we actually
do have a site within the village which
could take quite a few which is being
examined by the owners now so we do have
capacity in the village but there is no
demand at the moment anyway our latest
development that we did support which is
not far from there still has 20% that
its housing stock for sale
that's afternoon II two years so we have
several properties which are still for
sale throughout the village it is taking
a long time for them to go no housing
needs assessment was produced for this
application and I think I know why the
design is poor mascara men pointed out
projects into open countryside it's not
in keeping with the landscape like
the northern boundary he said doesn't
even appear logical or natural it's out
of keeping with a linear nature of the
road it certainly is it takes up less
than one-third of a huge field and its
boundary of the development goes up to a
road which separates it from our local
sewage works what would be a suitable
name for development that close to a
sewage works what field sewage farm
development I don't know all the
fertilizer you can get and it's very
close this is not well thought through
isolated on a road which is medieval
where people cannot safely go down that
road now with a growing traffic you've
seen that there are no payments you can
see what would happen to a ghetto
development in an area where there is no
ability to mix with a community to be
part of a village they would be isolated
totally dependent on cars because our
bus service is scarcely existent mr.
cameras I think already done this idea I
don't think I need to add more I just
ask you to support us and he's
recommendations and thank you
thank you
questions just canceller parent thank
you you've mentioned that you are
developing your neighborhood plan and
that there is a site that you have
identified can you tell us where there
isn't how many dwellings there are
separate things the neighborhood plan is
under preparation now that is going
through we've carried out a survey of
the village the question now is now
being checked and my colleagues behind
me a whole part of that team so we all
know about I'd say at least her whole
way through the process of developing a
neighborhood plan to being sure that we
have control over unscrupulous building
on either side of the village but we are
looking at possibilities within the
village now I cannot say anything about
that because we need to wait for the
owner of that land to decide what they
want to do and then to discuss that with
our council and our village community do
you have any site allocations in India
for common plan at the moment we have
not reached a point where our plan we're
none of that stage not yet thank you was
that I did ask how many dwellings there
might be on this more potentially from
an application that was made years ago
but I think there would be fewer
dwellings offered if that were to be put
forward now we will anticipate something
like eight dwellings considering that
we've already built 22 in the last three
and a half years one or two of which are
still for sale I'd have thought for a
small village like ours that's pretty
good going thank you sorry um you said
you've built some recently is that a
rural exception site no the last
development was built by land X and that
was also originally a knockout site but
it was built with our agreement and
really are a great approval in the
village because it was on derelict land
which was once connected to a farm their
church farm and we felt that it was a
very good use of space because that lad
had not been
used for many years had old farm
buildings was over wrongly burning and
was not accessible to anyone now we have
a very pleasant very attractive
development and we also have a field
next to it which is open for all the
villagers to enjoy thank you
cancer that was born yeah Thank You mr.
chairman Barrett's don't know I just say
that the way you've taught on this
application is excellent just the final
point about the local plan how far have
you or nationally how long did you
actually remember did you say you've got
a timescale we wouldn't want to do that
at the moment because my colleagues
behind me including the gentleman is
going to speak to you next is a member
of that team right and they because
they've now had to get our questionnaire
back and we've had a very very large
response the village have been very
enthusiastic to show that they want to
be involved in controlling our future so
they're they're taking a long time to go
through the responses and I think they
were very close to completing that then
we can start to take those responses and
decide how we're going to apply them to
our long-term plan Thank You mr.
chairman might be a million dollar
question but how and I'm not trying to
be a JIT here at all but how is your
room your young people there how many
have you there in regard to the future
say that any application comes forward
will take at least three years anyway so
are you referring to the big families
children right
the situation with every suffered
village like ours is that we're aging
we're all getting older people tend to
go to a village like ours and they stay
them I'm sorry I'm going to put this in
context yeah yes but you are taking
rather
long time I think the answers need to be
a bit shorter all right I've been a
teacher for too many years I don't
apologize
the situation is that the number of
families in the village is easily
sufficient to sustain our school however
we have a situation where most local
schools no longer depend at all on the
local population of families many
parents now choose to send their
children to a school of their choice
unlike sixty years ago when you sent
your child in most cases down the road
and at the moment when the reasons why
they don't always send them down the
road it's quite dangerous to get down
there as you see cancer
areas Thank You Chet can I just come in
there I did live out of the village and
took my children to walk field so I
appreciate that people would come out of
the village but also I'd like to know
how is the traffic increase having had a
flat tire exactly on that stretch of
road and I changed myself the situation
deteriorates by the month and the
reasons are varied but it's connected
partly not just because of water from
airbase
there are many other reasons why
everyone travels by car I'm an exception
I tend to use a bike more in the village
very dangerous as well the situation
down that stretch of road is that we
have an SSID camera which we put up to
measure the intensity of traffic and
I've got the job of analyzing that every
couple of months and I analyze that this
weekend and the I'm sorry I'm going to
get it in the way of my colleague here
I'm sure even mention it but we know
that there are on average 2,000 cars a
day at the end of August and the first
week of September going through the
village this is provable data from our
si D and that worries us tremendously
because I've been doing this for two
years the trend is upwards our roads are
becoming more dangerous and more filled
with
hazard particularly for our youngsters
and older people thank you yeah thank
you and my second question was the
houses that are still up for sale can
you give me some indication of why
they're not being sold and expensive
well I'm not gonna mention the brexit
word because that puts off many people I
sure did you not see them we were
showing them well on our site inspection
pal I'm sorry I did give my apologies I
had to take throat ladies away but I do
know the village I didn't see you but
the places that I stood up for sale are
me we've got 20 percent of the ones in
their new development dr. so these were
promised above the average for the
village because they're new and they're
beautifully designed to keep your answer
short the other properties in the
village there are so much quite sheep
which haven't gone which I won't buy
cheap I mean 2-bedroom affordable more
and there are others of which are more
expensive we found that in a village
like ours they tend to take a long time
to sell because many families prefer not
to come into and a fairly isolated
community where their needs may well be
elsewhere for example closer to the edge
of a town so they tend to go but very
very slowly and at the moment
particularly sorry thank you any other
questions comes for Barrett I was
interested in the size of the population
of what what field a website about what
field and your population is recorded as
being a 310 no so I don't know which
website you saw but it's wrong our
population has gone up because of the
developments in the last few years so it
may well be that you're going back to
what was census information which could
have been you know 9 years ago but
because of the building that we've
allowed to take place it is now just
under 400 and a number of buildings of
course has gone up by 22
I think your figures know that figured
that we do have it here sorry counsel
back and just having a very quick look I
know I'm not just looking on the Suffolk
observatory with the most recent data
from 2017 to get the estimate there was
372 okay I don't know if we can we can
rely on on the same website but in 1838
it was 381 so I think there's still some
room they were all farming still some
room for the numbers to go up
I'm sure schoolteacher could give us the
history less about that thank you any
any other questions to the speaker no
okay thank you
okay could I just reiterate Jay what's
mentioned already by up I think I'm
splud and the previous ones the
neighborhood plan carries just about no
way at all at the moment so to
discussion about that and this together
you shouldn't really weigh on your and
consideration is very limited we have
John Bo's hell
you sir also have three minutes in which
to dress the committee and perhaps at
the end about you remain so if there's
any questions for you you're not a
school teacher sir are you because a
school teacher no ok this no disrespect
sir good morning John Bo tell Norton
Road my main concern is the volume of
traffic passing through our village I've
been an owner occupier in Norton Road
for over 30 years and in that time I've
seen an exponential increase in traffic
growth with two commuter bulges one
between 7:00 and 9:00 a.m. and the other
from 4:00 to 7:00 this proposed
development will only make matters worse
as many families now have two more or
more cars the planning officer has
recognized these concerns in his report
I'd like to explain a little bit more
detail the risks involved my fellow
resident has indicated that the speed
indicator devices show over two thousand
cars a day coming through this excludes
traffic to and from Elmo sit on the
other road you will be aware there are
no pedestrian pavements for the whole of
Norton Road and most of the village and
we do not have street lighting there is
a pinch point just outside Church
farmhouse and this is situated between
Norton Road and the rest of what fields
this narrows the road down to 4.6 meters
or 15 feet measured from the grass verge
to the opposite curb a bus or large
lorry is a minimum of two point two five
meters or eight feet wide
so it follows that one of two buses or
large lorries will have to give way for
the other to pass which will mean
pulling into the side or overlapping The
Verge there are several young families
that live in Norton Road itself
parents and children walking to our
primary school face a daily challenge
having to rely on good natured motorists
to give them room some solve this
problem by driving to school there
thereby further increasing traffic
but the older children returning from
hadley schools have no choice they have
to walk in the road between bus stops it
is noticeable that traffic leaving what
field in an easterly direction tends to
increase speed when passing the 30 miles
sign outside number 5 by the time it
reaches the other speed sign at the far
end of the road most of it will be
breaking the speed limit and approaching
50 miles an hour this will be even more
of a danger if another Road junction
comes directly into the road from the
proposed development additionally one
further matter the field Phylis
development is seasonal to flooding with
standing water which in wet winters
occurs in a large swathe opposite the
adjacent sewage works this water seeps
onto the old state road causing black
ice the sewage farm also causes a
noticeable increase in house flies and
mosquitoes in the summer which will be
far worse for any new residents nearby
from questionnaires taken as a part of
our village plan road safety is a major
worry
the residents of Norton Road and what
field as a whole thank you thank you
very much members do you have any
questions to the last speaker and agent
or County counselor
so we're now going to open debate and
the local okay thank you
my concerns are again pretty similar to
they were with the wheat fields
development as has been pointed out the
lack of services in the village and the
increased traffic the problem with this
one from the list and although it's
smaller than the wheat field house
development this one in the model in a
worse position traffic from this
development they have to go either
through what field at the end of the
village where the reason and footpaths
and this has been pointed out when
there's pinch points through Knowlton's
there Norton Road which is another small
village or down the single track
Road what field Road towards Elm set so
so I know Kevin Barrett pointed out this
may not be an issue because people might
have electric cars in the future and
people may have this shopping delivered
but there are all things that may happen
people who move into these will have
cars and they make it they do have but
we don't know these people will have so
he's gonna increase traffic in the
village he's going to put more pressure
on the village it has been pointed out
by the residents how it is a concern
they were worried about what effect it
will have
and this has been pointed out these
developments or we're getting it into
the village that took a long while to
sell and still up for sale so I mean
developing more properties doesn't
guarantee they're going to be sold thank
you thank you very much any comments any
other questions comments debate tents
low plumb horrible precedent if we
approve this one after having refused
the last one so I'd like to move
approval of the officers recommendations
do I have a seconder for that
councillor Norman do wish to comment
okay any other comments because it is
different to the last application which
I recommend it refused refusal of the
approval anyway I'm not gonna go again
it's the officer recommendation on this
one because it is at the other end of
the village it's away from the school it
does require pupils to probably
go onto the road at some stage on their
journey to school and it's rather mere
sewage works so for those reasons I'm
going to go with the officer recommend
it's been proposed by Chancellor plum
and seconded by Councillor norman that
we accept the officers recommendation
for refusal that set out in your papers
before you all those in favor please
show as soon nanus thank you good thank
you
Thank You mr. teacher
members would move on to page 75 for the
crown building subtree you've been so
good desire good after so yes
[Music]
you
sorry page 74 you and Jack are going you
Thank You chair so the final item is
item 6d it is for the crown building on
Newton Road and sorry this application
has been to committee before in outline
form and what we're here to determine
today is the details with regards to
landscaping and it is landscaping only
I'm not sure whether you can read that
clearly but just to provide context the
application reference dating back to
2018 has granted in November was for the
erection of up to 19 apartments this was
approved in outline form with select
details excluding landscaping another
application then came through a later
date
December 2018 it was approved as it was
section 73 application since then we've
had the latest application which was
granted August 20 19.2 long ago with
regards to discharge of conditions and
that related to agreement of materials
landscaping protection park landscape
scheme construction management surface
water drainage screen walls and fences
illumination fire hydrants and car
suckers so all we're here to determine
today is the landscaping detail that's
included on the plan so I will jump
through to the application site so on
the approach into Sudbury on the
right-hand side we have a derelict piece
of land which I believe as a former tax
office again principles established is
only the landscape and detail we're
looking at so the land does slope from
east down to west as you approach the
junction there are residential dwellings
to the north
and Bellevue opposite as you should
hopefully be able to relate to in terms
of the existing site there are good
quality trees along northern southern
boundaries and this is the proposed plan
simply for landscaping so I'll take you
through the colors if I may so there are
various turfed features throughout the
site the layout is fixed and approved
the scale is fixed and approved the axis
is fixed and approved we are looking at
purely landscaping so the blue hoops
which hopefully just relate to along
this northern boundary depict the
biggest and best trees that are to be
retained there's also some along the
southern boundary as well and towards
the back of the site what will be on the
lawn along the western boundary the pink
shows tarmacked areas for parking this
is wholly acceptable to your officers
and the orange depicts fence lines so
this is largely a relatively open site
once you get into site especially
naturally along boundary features you'd
expect a degree of privacy and the
scheme does provide for that I've jumped
through to the next slide which will
hopefully jog your memory
these are the more prominent trees along
the southern boundary adjacent to the
main road these will be retained sort of
ground level there would be fresh
planting in terms of shrubbery this is
the largest tree that is along the
northern boundary and again that same
tree as you can see you can just about
see the properties to the north behind
the established hedgerow there is a wall
amongst this that would be retained
effectively there were concerns raised
by nearby residents which related to the
value of property this is not a material
planning consideration I do raise it for
completeness
this is a view from the adjacent street
and again the frontage would be heavily
planted with low-level shrubbery so just
to confirm and summarize your office's
do support the proposal this is strictly
for landscaping with all other details
through and approved by committee and
the recommendation is for approval thank
you thank you very much well members
you'll be pleased today we don't have
any town council objector supporter
applicant agent or claim to counselor so
we go to the ward member which is also a
member of the committee
Chancellor age ozb all right Thank You
mr. chairman
first of all just a question to the to
Jack the town councils a response on
this was you have received in you I
can't just remember what their response
was to this was an invitation
their comments word-for-word because I
remember copying it across yeah approved
the landscaping scheme providing the
hedgerow that runs along the footpath be
maintained yeah fantastic yeah thank you
oh the other the other point was from
residents that were actually to the left
of the of the plant in the hedge where
the wall is his comment to me was the
width of the grass verge that runs from
that access round to newton road that is
not being reduced in any way that is
being kept the same he's he thought when
he looked at the plans that was been
reduced in width but it it obviously
isn't is it that is correct the width of
that verge would be retained as County
Council ownership secondly you're
probably looking at the width of a line
on a plan so in terms of plotting it
correctly that is well beyond the point
of return in terms of what has been
approved and what would be delivered
fantastic and there's obviously no roof
garden I know I've got no objection mr.
chairman and I'll go with the officers
recommendation thank you
I think that was roundabout away of a
recommendation to approve was it right
but I would take a second and then I'll
come to you
okay so Parker your second that would
you like to comment yeah just just
briefly sure yes I'm happy to second the
proposal just just for as a matter of
interest what why why is this come back
to us what was this not on the original
proposal I think the procedural
soundness the application is considered
as 19 units more than 15 units requires
determination by members this is a
spin-off application from that I either
detail so it had to come back I'm afraid
1990 Department so I was unaware of them
so I've now got
before well you might find your way
around oh then we won't go there if you
saw the emails going backwards and
forwards that it wasn't his area a bit
wait wait comment counselor as in stinky
chair I would like to second that
because of being young
oh sorry penciler a Hinton Thank You mr.
chair that's a quick comment if you also
could put up the first one we've got
like nice little colored blobs on it
that one yes why have we got some tarmac
areas and some permeability Ria's for
car parking why aren't they all the same
any particular reason why we've got the
red ones with your tarmac Daria's and
yet you've got a car sitting on that
permeable area I think you have to take
into account the gradient of the land
and indeed surface water runoff so I'm
not saying that these are gonna be as
such a gradient or slope that it's gonna
flood but at the same time it's a good
blend I think if you're going to tarmac
the entirety of the area the only thing
that would demand the difference between
the layout access by tarmac would be a
white line I think it's quite a good
design feature to have an alternative
tarmac or an alternative surface for
spaces it's good variety I wouldn't
argue with the permeable surfaces but I
would thought they would be more
preferable to the tarmac on the basis if
they were on the sloping some of the
water running down the slope and
flooding somebody else it would soak
through and again I think that's a fair
comment I wouldn't disagree to a degree
I think you've got a look at the
gradient in that particular area
we are sloping off down into Newton Road
at the same time dependent on levels
which are already approved they're going
to need to deliver a surface water
sealed surface water drainage compliant
scheme that's approved so the surface
that comes through with that is that our
own disposal hopefully that helps
canceler I was born
just just come back for my on that and I
agree with cancer Hinton here because
can you just clarify the position of
permanent all services because when
people put in drives they must be
paranormal services so why have we got a
situation like that was it accepted
obviously I agree you know except it was
accepted by my planning however it's a
it's a perma basalt of thought any
council will gone to see of course and I
think you know drainage details are well
beyond the point of return they are
approved let's look at it maximally if
the entirety of the site was to be a
sealed surface surface waters we have to
run off somewhere I think in your
consideration of a driveway if someone
puts in a permeable driveway it would
have to be porous and seep through to
comply with plan and law similarly if
you're going to be providing a sealed
surface you'd have to provide an eco
drain so that it runs off it it soaks
away elsewhere this scheme would be no
different however it would be diverted
elsewhere within the site thank you I
can see if it was all permeable it would
look and look a lot better in terms of
ecological reasons and all the rest of
it if it says cancer Osborn is
indicating due to finance and so so
being that's tell them to spend a bit
more at this point yeah I agree with the
council the internet obviously I can't I
can't say what the applicants got in
funding for doing these doing these
things and cannot just my final thing is
can I just thank Jack for the effort he
has put into this application it has
been a considerable long length of time
and he eventually got there and I know
he said quite a lot of responses to be
able to make to residents locally around
that area thank you thank you jack
thank thank you for that I think it's
worth noting that most of our planning
officers
and I've already congratulated jack on
he's preview as well but I think most of
our plan and officers do put in a lot of
work and and we are supported by good
officers and the Planning Committee and
I'd go as far as to say the tensile or
the top of the distance I was concerned
but anyway that get me to trouble I know
any other comments members know I've had
a proposal from councillors Osborne
seconded by Councillor Parker that we
accept the officers recommendation of
approval as set out in your papers we
for you all those in favor please show
another unanimous decision brought up
thank you well that they've got all the
hold enough so I think they're about to
start so there's no site inspection next
Wednesday so the date of the next
committee meeting is scheduled for
Wednesday the 9th of October at 9:30
thank you very much
[Applause]